Hey all, it's The Office Ladies, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
大家好，我是《办公室女士》的珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金西。
And we are so excited to present to you Season 3 of How We Made Your Mother with Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
我们非常高兴向大家呈现《老爸老妈浪漫史》幕后揭秘第三季，嘉宾是乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯。
Enjoy!
尽情享受吧！
Woohoo!
呜呼！
to how we made your mother, this is our first episode of season three, can you believe it, Craig?
欢迎收听《老爸老妈浪漫史》幕后揭秘，这是我们第三季的第一集，你能相信吗，克雷格？
I cannot believe it.
我简直不敢相信。
It's going to, I guess we're having fun because it's going too fast.
我想，我们会觉得好玩是因为时间过得太快了。
That's crazy.
太疯狂了。
It's going fast.
时间过得真快。
I'm actually freaked out that we're already in season three.
一想到我们已经进入第三季了，我其实有点被吓到了。
Let me ask you this, Craig Thomas, my co-host of How We Made Your Mother.
我问你个问题，克雷格·托马斯，我的《老爸老妈浪漫史》幕后揭秘联合主持人。
Oh, hi.
哦，嗨。
What did you do on your three week summer hiatus?
你这三周的暑假都干什么了？
I had the shortest summer hiatus.
我度过了最短的暑假。
Yeah, and it wasn't summer, which was also weird for a summer hiatus.
对，而且也不是夏天，这对于暑假来说也挺奇怪的。
My daughter was studying the Revolutionary War, so we went for her spring break to Philadelphia, where I saw in person the Liberty Bell for the first time.
我女儿当时在学美国独立战争史，所以在她春假期间，我们去了费城，在那里我第一次亲眼看到了自由钟。
Even though we wrote a whole episode about looking at it, I had never been there in actual life.
尽管我们曾写过一整集关于看自由钟的剧情，但我现实生活中从没去过那里。
And I tweeted about this years ago, I seriously want to talk to a security guard at the Liberty Bell and see how many hymnum fans they had to tackle or I should have asked and I didn't.
我几年前还在推特上发过这个，我真的很想跟自由钟的保安聊聊，看看他们得拦下多少“老爸老妈”粉丝，或者我本该问问的，但我没问。
but then I posted a picture of me there and a lot of people then sent me their pictures of them like pretending to lick it, like sort of a Trump loy, like they're sort of licking it, they're tend to eat in front of it, and they're kind of licking it.
但后来我发了一张我在那里的照片，然后很多人就发给我他们假装舔自由钟的照片，就像川普那样，他们假装在舔，在它前面假装要吃掉它，然后就那么舔着。
And then I regretted that I didn't do that photo because it was like, just go back and check it out.
然后我很后悔我当时没拍那样的照片，就觉得，真该回去补一张。
When was, so first season was like 2005.
什么时候，所以第一季大概是2005年。
So you work at the Liberty Bell, you're like, you're working there.
所以你在自由钟工作，你就在那儿上班。
And all of a sudden, it's a wave of weirdos coming to the Liberty Bell and licking it, and you're like, you don't know.
然后突然之间，涌现出一波怪人来到自由钟前狂舔，而你根本一无所知。
You don't know, you've not watched how I met your mother.
你完全不知道，你没看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
There's like now a dedicated guy who's like, and now you're the lick, you're the lick guy.
现在有个专职人员心想：“好吧，现在你成了‘舔钟哥’了。”
You're the stopping people from licking it specialist.
你成了“阻止人们舔钟的专家”。
That's how much, that's how the cultural footprint that this show has left, has affected everyone.
这就是这部剧留下的文化影响力，它影响了每个人。
Even if you didn't watch it.
哪怕你没看过。
Fans sent me many, many pictures of them pretending to lick it.
粉丝们发给我好多好多他们假装舔自由钟的照片。
I don't know, I would love to know if anyone knows this, if anyone really ever did lick it.
我不知道，我很想知道有没有人知道，是否真的有人去舔过它。
Please not a joke.
请告诉我这不是个玩笑。
If you have lick the Liberty Bell or know someone like Liberty Bell.
如果你舔过自由钟或者认识舔过自由钟的人。
Or read a local story in Philadelphia about the guy they got arrested for licking it.
或者在费城当地新闻里读到过哪个家伙因为舔自由钟而被捕。
And then we should probably be like, buy that guy dinner or something.
那我们大概应该请那家伙吃顿晚饭什么的。
We know that there's people who've who've done the Naked Man, which I think is illegal in most states.
我们知道有些人真的演过“光棍男”（The Naked Man），这在大多数州我想都是违法的。
I think I know.
我想我知道。
I've seen that.
我见过。
Yeah.
对。
Most states.
大多数州。
Yeah.
对。
Every state.
每个州。
Don't do the Naked Man.
千万别去搞什么光棍男。
But, but if you want to look, don't lick the Liberty Bell.
但是，但是如果你想去看看，千万别舔自由钟。
Wink, wink.
眨眼，眨眼。
We can't.
我们可不能。
我们可不能这么说。
Let us know.
让我们知道。
Let us know if you've been to Philadelphia and it'll just like Greg.
如果你去过费城，请告诉我们……
but that's fantastic.
但这太棒了。
Yeah, I felt a sense of completeness that I always felt a little bit like a fraud because we did all of this whole episode and I had never been and it felt if it was good, it was good to get there and really do it.
对，我有一种圆满的感觉，我以前总觉得自己有点像个骗子，因为我们拍了整整一集，但我自己却从没去过，能去那里实地打卡感觉真好。
And I went to Boston and saw more of a Revolutionary War stuff because my daughter's studying that.
我还去了波士顿看了更多独立战争的遗迹，因为我女儿在学那个。
And I got to go to the Cheers Bar, which is Cheers is my all time favorite said comment I'd never been there and I went there and I bought my daughter and my wife in.
我还去了干杯酒吧（Cheers Bar），干杯是我有史以来最喜欢的处景喜剧，我以前从没去过，我带了我女儿和我老婆一起进去。
And as I talked about my love for Cheers, I started to cry slightly.
当我倾诉我对《干杯》的热爱时，我有点感动得哭了。
And then every time we, our hotel was, I liked that so much that show meant to me.
然后每次我们，我们的酒店就在……那部剧对我的意义太重大了。
And then every time we would pass the cheers bar during our time in Boston, my daughter would go, is dad going to cry again now?
结果我们在波士顿期间，每次路过干杯酒吧，我女儿就会说：“爸爸现在又要哭了吗？”
So I was getting heckled about my love of cheers.
所以我因为热爱《干杯》而遭到她的调侃。
She seems like she would have done well on the how I met your mother couch, rolling her eyes.
她看起来挺适合坐在《老爸老妈浪漫史》的沙发上翻白眼的。
You have no idea.
你根本想象不到。
Just.
简直了。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
Yeah.
对。
What did you do?
你干嘛去了？
What were your, what was your child?
你的，你的孩子呢？
I've been raising.
我一直在养育。
Oh, is he, is the full grown adult?
哦，他，他是成年人了吗？
No, he's off to, off to Wesley and in the fall.
不，他秋天就要去卫斯理安大学了。
You really spent through that.
你这话题切入得真快。
That was the thing.
就是这样。
I was like, I'm not gonna waste time on this.
当时我想：我才不在这种事上浪费时间呢。
Let's get him up and running.
赶紧让他麻溜上大学去。
No, we mostly been here.
不，我们大部分时间都在这儿。
I did take him to Columbus, Ohio to see my family.
我确实带他去过俄亥俄州哥伦布市看望我的家人。
Jordana's best friend had a bachelorette thing in Maine that she was at.
佐丹娜（Jordana）的最好朋友在缅因州有一个单身派对，她在那里。
And I was gonna go see my family and I had to fly with our son for the first time.
我原本打算去看望家人，结果我不得不第一次带着我们的儿子坐飞机。
Ooh, that's a really, that's a little crowder.
哦，那可真是一个，那可真够挤的。
That's a little dude to fly with.
带那么小的娃坐飞机真不容易。
Yeah, five and a half months.
对，五个半月大。
Although I was told, and this is true, they said, a man alone in an airport with a baby, you'll be treated like a king.
虽然有人告诉我，而且这是真的，他们说：“一个男人独自带着婴儿在机场，你会受到国王般的对待。”
It said, everyone thinks you're a hero.
他们说，每个人都觉得你是英雄。
Did you get that?
你受到了这种待遇吗？
Did that, was that true?
真的吗？那是真的吗？
100%.
100%。
百分之百。百分之百。
Especially on the way back, for some reason, there was even more.
特别是回程的时候，不知为什么，待遇更夸张了。
But yeah, it was- That's really funny.
但是，这——真的太搞笑了。
And it was a very unfair.
而且这很不公平。
But I met a woman who, her son was nine, I met her the weekend before at a thing, And she, her son's like a world traveler.
但我遇到了一位女士，她的儿子九岁，我前一个周末在一个活动上认识了她，她的儿子简直是个世界旅行家。
Like they've been everywhere with this kid.
他们带着这孩子去过各种地方。
So she sent me like a huge list.
所以她给我发了一大长串清单。
There's all sorts of tricks.
里面全都是各种小技巧。
Like you feed a bottle when they're taking off because it helps with the ear, the counter pressure and all that stuff.
比如飞机起飞时给他们喂奶瓶，因为这有助于缓解耳压和反压力之类的事情。
A bottle of gin.
一瓶杜松子酒。
So it ended up to be okay.
所以最后结果还不错。
And also my sister's kids are like 14 to 19.
而且我姐姐的孩子们大概14到19岁。
Like they're much older.
他们大得多。
And my sisters are actually great with babies.
而且我姐姐们其实很擅长带婴儿。
So the moment I got there, I was like, take this baby, you know, and they just like immediately took, took him off my hands and we're just not enough.
所以我一到那儿就说：“把这孩子抱走吧，”你知道的，她们就立刻把孩子从我手里接过去，然后我们就……
Huge respect for flying by yourself with a five and a half month old baby.
一个人带着五个半月大的婴儿独自坐飞机，我对你肃然起敬。
Yeah.
谢啦。
I definitely 100% never did that with either one of my children.
我绝对、百分之百地从没跟我俩的任何一个孩子干过这事。
Yeah.
对。
So at that young of an age, so.
所以，在那么小的年纪，所以。
Well done.
干得漂亮。
Yeah.
对。
And a woman doing the exact same thing wouldn't get shit.
而且女人做一模一样的事，根本屁事没有。
She'd get no one would say anything.
她会——没人会说什么。
It's so sad, but, but that was a big, I, I felt a lot of like dad's self esteem.
这太悲哀了，不过，那是一个很大的，我，我感觉找回了很多身为父亲的自尊。
Yeah.
对。
I felt like I did this.
我感觉我做到了。
I can do this.
我能行。
And also I can move through the world with this baby, right?
而且我还能带着这个宝宝去外面闯荡，对吧？
It's not just a hostage situation in your lovely apartment in Brooklyn.
这不只是你在布鲁克林可爱公寓里的一场人质劫持危机。
It's I get to move through the world sometimes too.
而是有时候我也能带着孩子去外面走走。
And it's nice, it's nice to remember that.
这感觉很好，能记起这一点感觉真好。
You can see the family and so that was great.
你能去见见家人，所以那真的很棒。
I mean, that was a big notable thing over our little tiny hiatus.
我是说，那是我们短暂休假期间一件非常引人注目的大事。
What did we have for how many other, we had like four and a half months, like you could really do things.
我们休息了多久来着，我们大概休了四个半月，你真的能做很多事。
The actors had more than the writers.
演员比编剧休假的时间长。
That's true.
确实。
He says, come on literally.
他说，拜托，真的。
This is always the thing I forget.
这是我总是忘记的事。
This is my little extra crack.
这是我额外的一点小乐趣。
What did you guys do this summer?
你们这夏天都干嘛了？
Wrote the goddamn show, actors.
写那该死的剧本呗，演员们。
Nice tan.
晒得挺黑。
But you looked as super tan and all races.
但你看起来超级黑，各种肤色的人。
You looked super tan.
你看起来超级黑。
That happened every time in August when you guys came back.
每次八月份你们回来的时候都会这样。
So we take like, what, we would take May and June and start up sometime in the writer's room and I don't know, late June or July.
所以我们大概，我们会用五月和六月休息，然后在编剧室开始工作，大概是在六月下旬或七月的某个时候。
I'm probably getting it wrong.
我可能记错了。
It's something like that.
大概是那样吧。
So that we had five or six scripts written in some state of being written by one would be shooting mid-August, late August.
所以我们会有五六集剧本写好，处于某种写作状态中，大约八月中旬、八月下旬就要开拍了。
And this was a bit, we were talking about this before we started recording.
这就是我们之前在开始录制前谈论的一个话题。
This was a big, between season two and season three, that was a big hiatus in your life and my life in very different ways.
这是很大的一件事，在第二季和第三季之间，在你的生活和我的生活中，那是一个截然不同的巨大假期。
A lot happened in our personal lives and in our psyches and in our souls during that time.
在那期间，我们的个人生活、心理和精神状态都发生了很大变化。
So much so that we're gonna talk about it as its own separate, but let's just see it up a little bit.
变化太大了，以至于我们要把它当作一个独立的话题来聊，但让我们先简单铺垫一下。
So that was the summer your son was born, Elliot between seasons two and three.
所以那是你儿子埃利奥特出生的那个夏天，在第二季和第三季之间。
Yes.
对。
Yeah, my son Elliot was more between seasons two and three and talked about this on the pod before, but it was very unexpectedly challenging and chaotic.
对，我儿子埃利奥特就是在第二季和第三季之间出生的，之前在播客里也聊过这个，但这非常出乎意料地充满了挑战和混乱。
He had, he was born with a rare genetic syndrome.
他，他出生时患有一种罕见的基因综合征。
We had no idea in utero, like he was born and something was wrong and he was lower weight and he wasn't breathing quite right.
我们在子宫里时完全不知道，他出生时就出了问题，体重偏低，呼吸也不太顺畅。
He turned out he had multiple heart defects it's rare genetic syndrome.
后来发现他有多种心脏缺陷，这是一种罕见的基因综合征。
He needed open heart surgery at two weeks old in Children's Hospital, Los Angeles saved his life without question.
他在两周大时就需要进行心脏开心手术，洛杉矶儿童医院毫无疑问地救了他的命。
And this was all happening between we finished season two and season three was the barreling towards me.
这一切都发生在第二季结束和向我们飞速逼近的第三季之间。
And it was like I was in the neonatal intensive care unit at CHLA where they're for almost six weeks.
当时就像是我在洛杉矶儿童医院的新生儿重症监护室里待了近六周。
And this is my first kid, this is my introduction to parenthood and being told he's gonna have all these challenges in life.
这是我的第一个孩子，这是我为人父母的初体验，却被告知他在人生中将面临所有这些挑战。
And it was really, really hard.
那段经历真的、真的很艰难。
So coming back to season three was weird and hard and also so healing and great to get to come back and be creative with these people I love, yourself very much included.
所以回到第三季既诡异又艰难，同时也极其治愈，能回来和这些我爱的人——当然非常包括你在内——一起搞创作，感觉太棒了。
And so I have a lab to say about that journey at some point.
所以我到时候有很多话想聊聊那段心路历程。
What was the name of the podcast you wanted to do?
你原本想做的那个播客叫什么名字来着？
Yeah, well, maybe we'll still do this one day.
对，好吧，也许我们有一天还是会做这个。
We wanted to do a pod game.
我们当时想做一个播客节目。
So when I would come to the writer's room at the very start of season three, I'd first go to Carter's office or my office and sit just with Carter and me alone in a room, knowing that we had to launch season three, day one of season three and day two and day three.
所以当我来到第三季刚开始时的编剧室时，我会先去卡特的办公室或者我的办公室，就我和卡特两个人单独坐在房间里，明知我们必须开启第三季，第三季的第一天、第二天和第三天。
And every morning we would sit down on the couch and we'd just look at each other and I looked like a shell of a human being.
每天早上我们都会坐在沙发上，互相看着对方，而我看起来就像个行尸走肉。
I was just gray and I just looked like I was dying.
我面色灰白，看起来就像快要死了一样。
And we'd look at each other and go, now go be funny.
然后我们看着对方说，现在去搞笑吧。
Yeah, now go be funny.
对，现在去搞笑吧。
I wanted to and maybe still want to do a vodcast or maybe we could just sort of trojan horse it into this podcast and just talk about it here.
我当时想、而且可能现在还想做一个视频播客，或者我们可以把它当作特洛伊木马计划偷偷塞进这个播客里，就在这里聊聊。
But just that idea of how do you go make comedy when you're going through the darkest thing and that you can almost possibly go through.
但就是那种想法：当你经历着可能经历的最黑暗的事情时，你该如何去创作喜剧？
And that was the now go be funny of it all.
这就是这一切中“现在去搞笑吧”的含义。
Yeah.
对。
Wow.
哇。
Well, I'd have to go do that.
好吧，我得去这么做。
It was really looking forward to doing a deeper dive with you just talking about those summers.
我真的很期待能和你深入探讨，专门聊聊那些夏天。
That's that summer in particular.
特别是那个夏天。
Me too.
我也是。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, I mean, I'll just tee up mine.
对，我的话，我先抛个砖。
I maybe due to some kind of weird combination combination of, you know, being destabilized from losing anonymity and being on this show.
我可能是因为某种诡异的组合拳，你知道的，从失去匿名性、参演这部剧带来的失控感。
And I don't know.
我不知道。
I just needed something.
我只是需要点什么。
I needed a spiritual chiropractic adjustment.
我需要进行一次精神上的脊椎按摩。
So I ended up going to Brazil and then Colombia.
所以我最后去了巴西，然后去了哥伦比亚。
I worked with an ancient Amazonian plant medicine called ayahuasca.
我使用了一种古老的亚马逊雨林植物药剂，叫做死藤水。
This is 2007.
那是2007年。
And it really changed my life and opened me up in all sorts of wonderful, magical ways, and it kind of changed my relationship with the show, it changed my relationship, but interestingly, because this does segue into, I told Jordana when we were watching it, because we have that flashback to the end of season two.
它真的改变了我的生活，以各种美妙、神奇的方式打开了我，它某种程度上改变了我与这部剧的关系，改变了我的关系，但有趣的是，因为这正好能承接我之前告诉乔丹娜的话，当时我们在看剧，因为我们看到了第二季结尾的那个闪回镜头。
And I pointed to her, I said, pre-Iowaska, and then it cuts back to me, you know, in season three, I said post-Iowaska.
我指着它对她说，这是“死藤水前”的我，然后镜头切回我身上，你知道的，在第三季里，我说这是“死藤水后”的我。
And I'm telling you, to me, I look like I'm clearer behind the eyes.
我跟你说，我觉得我眼神里看起来清澈多了。
I look like there's been some kind of change because I was, I also stopped drinking and I remember I was drinking a lot in season two and I could kind of see it in my face and I just felt so much healthier when I came back for season three.
我看起来好像发生了一些某种改变，因为我，我也戒酒了，我记得我在第二季的时候喝了很多酒，我能在自己的脸上看出这一点，当我回到第三季时，我感觉自己健康多了。
So much felt different and it was strange to be thrown back into this network sitcom after those, you know, yeah, in crazy adventures down there.
很多事情都感觉不同了，在经历了那些（你知道的）在南方的疯狂冒险之后，突然又被扔回这个电视网情景喜剧里，这种感觉很奇妙。
Yeah.
对。
But I actually found myself loving these two, these first two episodes that, that last night with Jordana.
但实际上我发现自己很喜欢这两集，这前两集，昨晚和乔丹娜一起看的那些。
But let's, we're talking about episode one of season three right now, which is called, which is called wait for it, which because we ended season two in the middle of a, we ended it on a wait for it midward.
不过我们现在在聊第三季的第一集，叫做，叫做——等等党，因为我们在第二季结尾时卡在了一个，我们在一个“等等党”的中场悬念结束了第二季。
I love that we ended before the final syllable, the final two syllables of the dairy.
我太喜欢我们在最后一音节、在乳制品（dairy）的最后两个音节之前戛然而止了。
And then we finish it.
然后我们把它演完。
We have to wait all summer to finish a single word.
我们得等上一整个夏天才能听完一个单词。
I really, that's one of my favorites.
我真的很喜欢，这是我的最爱之一。
It's kind of the Marshall making popcorn, but longer.
这有点像马歇尔爆米花，但时间更长。
It's the full summer popcorn.
这是整整一个夏天的爆米花。
But yeah, I, it's funny just to go off what you just said.
但是，对，我，顺着你刚才的话说挺有意思的。
I did feel like you had a very loose, like, um, in the, in the pocket, in the flow kind of energy right off the bat in, in this episode, like it, it very much begins, it begins with this great TED cold open.
我确实觉得你在这集的开头，就有一种非常随性、放松、像是在状态里的节奏。
If we're just diving and talking about it where you have this beard.
就像它非常直接地开始于一个很棒的泰德冷开场。
Josh Radner has this beard and Ted has this beard.
如果我们直接切入并讨论它的话，那就是你留了胡子的那个场景。
And it was your pitch, which again, is like, you came in cooking, you were like, I gotta get rid of this beard in real life.
乔什·拉德纳留了胡子，泰德也留了胡子。
Like, and I actually am going to shave this beard.
这是你的点子，再次说明，你当时状态正火，你说：“我得在现实生活中把这胡子刮了。”
And you said, whenever a guy shaves a beard.
就像，我真的打算把这胡子刮掉。
Hold on real quick.
然后你说，每当一个男人刮掉胡子……
No, you helped me tell it.
等一下，马上。
No, no, no, but I just want to make sure.
不，你帮我讲。
Was the breakup beard, it was in the script before I even said this.
是分手胡子，在我说出口之前剧本里就有了。
And I can't remember chicken or the egg because maybe you told us you were coming home with a big beard.
我不记得是先有鸡还是先有蛋了，因为可能你跟我们说过你要带着一大把胡子回家。
Oh, maybe.
哦，也许吧。
because it's a break up beer.
因为这是分手的胡子。
I don't remember if he thought of it.
我不记得是不是他想到的。
It's also funny, isn't it funny?
这也挺搞笑的，不觉得很好笑吗？
This is just occurring to me.
我刚刚才想起来。
It's all about Robin had been in South America, but I had actually been in South America.
这完全是罗宾去过南美洲的事，但其实是我去过南美洲。
It's so weird.
太诡异了。
Robin's plot was actually what you did.
罗宾的剧情实际上就是你做过的事。
It's so weird.
太诡异了。
I had sex with a guy on a wincer thing.
我和一个家伙在温瑟（音译）的东西上发生了关系。
That's a really attractive dude.
那是个很有魅力的帅哥。
Yeah, I had sex on a wincer thing forward.
对，我在温瑟那个东西上和人发生了关系。
Yeah, no, so here was my memory of it.
对，不，这是我的记忆。
This is how I remember it.
我是这么记的。
The breakup beard was written, But the way it was in the Monday draft we read was he goes into the bathroom and he comes out and he's clean shaven.
剧本里确实写了分手胡子，但我们读的周一初稿里的情节是，他走进浴室，出来时把胡子刮得精光。
And that's when I pulled you in Carter's side and I said, no man in the history of the world with a full beard shaves just completely.
就是那时我把你拉到卡特身边，我说，世界上没有任何一个留着满脸大胡子的男人会把胡子一下子全刮掉。
You shave in chops, you shave in a soul patch, you shave in a goat.
你会先刮掉鬓角，留一小撮魂灵须，或者留个山羊胡。
You stop and you stop and you see, what would I look like with a mustache?
你会停下来，照照镜子想，我留胡子会是什么样？
What would I look like?
我看起来会怎样？
Here's me as Hitler.
这是我留希特勒式胡子的样子。
We didn't do Hitler, but you know what I mean?
我们没弄希特勒那个，但你知道我的意思吧？
Like here's what I would look like.
就像我看看自己会是什么样。
So I pitched that, and people ask me like, oh, how much did you guys, and there's a couple things that I remember I pitched, and this was one of them.
所以我提出了这个建议，人们经常问我，哦，你们自己发挥了多少，有些事我还记得是我提议的，这就是其中之一。
I didn't write all the jokes that you guys came up with Chester A.
我没有写你们想出来的所有笑话，比如切斯特·A·
Arthur, Persian nightclub owner, like all of those.
亚瑟、波斯夜总会老板，诸如此类的。
But you gave us, you gave us the candy store to go play in.
但你给我们提供了一个可以自由发挥的糖果屋。
Yeah, I said he should come out each time with a different variation.
对，我说他每次出来时胡子都应该有不同的变化。
And also one thing I really like about it is he doesn't comment on it, they comment on it.
而且我特别喜欢的一点是，他自己不评判这事，是别人在评判。
Like he just comes out and he's in his own thing.
就像他走出来，完全沉浸在自己的世界里。
He's in his own thing about Robin and about just like, yeah, and coming back.
他沉浸在关于罗宾以及关于归来的世界里。
Yeah, did you, the literally how that was done, was it like we would shoot those takes, cause I was on to my wife Rebecca and she was like, you must have had to be very confident.
对，当时拍那一幕的时候，实际上是怎么拍的呢？因为我跟我妻子丽贝卡说过这事，她说，你当时一定得非常有自信。
You got those takes right before Josh runs off and like hair and makeup takes more off that beard.
你得在乔什跑开去让发型和化妆师再修剪掉一些胡子之前，把那些镜头一次拍好。
And I was like, yeah, I guess we really had to be sure that we really, the audio was good.
我就想，对，我想我们当时确实得确保万无一失，确保音频质量没问题。
I do remember that they wouldn't, they didn't shave me on set.
我确实记得他们不会在片场给我刮胡子。
Like I had to go outside to the hair and makeup trailer each time.
每次我都得走到外面的发型和化妆车里去。
I forgot that.
我都忘了这事了。
I was wondering if someone was waiting right off, but I guess not.
我当时还纳闷是不是有人就在旁边等着，但看来没有。
We had to stop it.
我们得停下来。
We had time, we had time.
我们有时间，我们有时间。
So yeah, I do remember that.
所以，是的，我确实记得。
And I think beards are makeup, right?
而且我觉得胡子也算化妆，对吧？
So that was Lona who would have been shaving me.
所以当时应该是洛娜负责给我刮胡子。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
And they all looked great.
而且它们看起来都挺棒的。
Or maybe Jen did.
或者也许是珍。
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
You had a hell of a beard.
你留了一副了不得的胡子。
That was a hell of a beard.
那真是一副了不得的胡子。
That was a good beard.
那胡子真不错。
That was a big, that was like a full, that was very fun.
那是一大把，非常浓密，特别有趣。
Those bits were great.
那些桥段太棒了。
And so it just, it's shot out of a cannon right away.
所以它就像一炮而红一样，一上来就抓住了眼球。
I love picking up on the dairy.
我特别喜欢接着上一季结尾拍。
I just love, I love the way we ended season two, coming right back on that.
我就是喜欢，我喜欢第二季结尾的处理方式，紧接着那个情节开始。
And then that way of getting through the summer and jumping all that time, and you have a beard, it feels like a summer past.
然后用这种方式度过夏天并跳过这段时间，你留了胡子，感觉就像夏天过去了。
Cause it really did.
因为确实如此。
And you really passed.
而你也确实度过了这段时间。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Time has passed.
时间流逝了。
It was, that was again, like honoring, like we did Halloween when it was Halloween.
这又是那种致敬，就像我们在万圣节时就演万圣节。
We did New Year's when it was new.
我们在新年时就演新年。
You know, we were, which wouldn't happen anymore.
你知道的，我们当时就是这样，现在在流媒体上已经不会这样了。
I'm streaming.
我是说流媒体。
No, it doesn't.
不，不会了。
No one does this anymore, but we really did wet ourselves to the air dates in a way.
现在没人这么做了，但我们当时确实在某种程度上紧跟播出日期。
Yeah.
对。
And I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City.
我为你写了这首小曲儿，要在纽约市唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，《Hyper-Fixed》播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并试着为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30, and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这些问题：我30岁了，但害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么当我挂倒车档时，不能调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你遇到了问题，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的背后隐蔽系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的《Hyper-Fixed》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台或访问 HyperFixedPod.com 找到它。
And now, back to the show.
现在，让我们回到节目中。
So for people who haven't seen it or maybe haven't seen it for a while, just remind us what happens in this episode.
所以对于那些没看过或者可能很久没看这集的人，请提醒我们这集里发生了什么。
Like what's the general shape in this episode?
这集的大致走向是怎样的？
General shape?
大致走向？
Nice.
不错。
General in many beard shapes.
各种胡子走向的大致形状。
The big question of this episode is this idea of who's winning the breakup, Ted and Robin broke up at the end of season two.
这一集的核心问题是关于“谁在分手大战中获胜”这个概念，泰德和罗宾在第二季末尾分手了。
And it's that thing of like, well, we're all still going to be friends, I guess.
然后就是那种情况，嗯，我想我们大家以后还是好朋友。
She was away for a bunch of the summer.
她整个夏天都不在。
They haven't seen each other.
他们一直没见。
What's it going to be like?
情况会变成什么样？
She comes back with this really hot dude in Ricky Iglesias and Ted realizes it's on.
她带着一个超级性感的帅哥里奇·伊格莱西亚斯回来了，泰德意识到大战开始了。
The competition is on.
竞争开始了。
I have to prove that I have to win this breakup.
我必须证明自己，我一定要赢下这场分手。
She's trying to win it.
她也在试图赢。
clearly trying to win it, but I have to win it.
显然在试图赢，但我必须赢。
And I think that's a very real thing.
我觉得这非常真实。
And then the sub, the sort of B plot of it is this other interesting philosophical question of, what do you owe to your friend?
然后副线，也就是所谓的B线剧情，是另一个有趣的哲学问题：你对朋友负有什么责任？
Or what if God forbid two of your friends were in a relationship and they break up?
或者，如果上帝保佑，你的两个朋友谈恋爱了然后分手了，会怎么样？
And of course, Lillian Marshall goes so much farther back with Ted.
当然，莉莉和马歇尔和泰德认识的时间要久得多。
But they love Robin and is it their duty to just abjectly hate Robin's new guy and agree with Ted that Robin is trying to win the breakup and being nefarious.
但他们也爱罗宾，那他们的责任是不是就该彻底痛恨罗宾的新男友，并且同意泰德的看法，认为罗宾是在试图赢下这场分手并且居心叵测？
Or are they allowed to think, well, Robin's happy and you're wrong, Ted.
或者他们可以这么想：罗宾很开心，而你错了，泰德。
This is not some conspiracy against you.
这并不是什么针对你的阴谋。
And so I love them being sort of seduced into liking.
所以我也喜欢看他们被诱导着去喜欢。
They can't help but sort of fall in love with the big egg laziest, so those are the two threads.
他们不由自主地开始喜欢上那个大蛋头，所以这是两条主线。
The power of it is over, it would overwhelm anyone.
这种力量太强大了，任何人都无法抵挡。
Yes, and they get very seduced, Marshall included.
是的，他们深深地被吸引了，马修也不例外。
I remember really thinking it was funny when we are all in the booth mispronouncing, like our inability to pronounce his name.
我还记得我们当时在录音棚里故意发音不准，觉得挺好笑的，比如我们就是发不好他的名字。
Girl?
女孩？
How'd you guys decide on Argentina?
你们是怎么决定去阿根廷的？
Like, where did that come from?
比如，这个点子是从哪里来的？
Like, I know it was planted that Robin, like, didn't she say in the break?
我知道这是之前铺垫好的，罗宾不是在休息时说过吗？
Like, I haven't ever been to Argentina.
比如，我从来没去过阿根廷。
Like, that was kind of like it.
差不多就是这样。
That's why we call this shot.
这就是我们为什么这样设计。
We said, and the minute she's single again, if she's saying I'm single, I want to be single because I want to go explore the world and be a journalist and go have adventures, we thought that she has to go do that.
我们当时说，她单身的那一刻起，如果她说我单身，我想单身是因为我想去探索世界，当个记者去经历冒险，我们就觉得她必须去这样做。
She broke up with Ted to go do things like that freely on her own and that's why.
她和泰德分手就是为了自由自在地去做这些事情，这就是原因。
It's a great, you know, cause you guys are exploring all aspects of being in relationships and of course, ending relationships.
这真的很棒，你知道的，因为你们在探讨恋爱关系的方方面面，当然也包括结束恋关系。
And then who are you when you're out of a relationship?
然后当你结束一段关系时，你又是谁呢？
I know that for me, I didn't have particularly good boundaries in my 20s, certainly in relationships.
我知道对我来说，我在二十多岁时并没有特别好的界限感，在恋爱中尤其如此。
So relationships, especially those early breakups, are so hard because you don't know yourself as well, and you end up kind of wedding yourself, not literally, but like you, there's just more codependency, you just get, and I think that it's a really great thing to explore, like, who are you now that you're no longer relationally kind of tied to this person?
所以恋爱关系，尤其是那些早期的分手，是如此艰难，因为你对自己的了解还不够深，到最后你会把自我和对方绑在一起，倒不是字面意义上的结婚，而是你会产生更多共生依赖，你就会……我觉得去探讨这样一个问题真的很好：既然你在关系上不再和这个人纠缠在一起了，现在的你究竟是谁？
And what does it do to this group?
这对这个群体又会产生什么影响？
Each season of the show very much mixes up the biological ecosystem of this little world of these people.
节目的每一季都在很大程度上打乱这群小圈子里人们的生物生态系统。
And that was one of the main takeaways of this episode.
这也是这一集的主要收获之一。
I was like, as proud of us that every season we really shook up the yet just sketch.
我就觉得，我们挺骄傲的，每一季我们真的都在打破常规。
And we said, let's draw a new picture.
我们当时说，让我们重新画一幅画吧。
Let's see what this is now.
让我们看看现在会是什么样。
Cause the dynamic has really changed right, right away.
因为这种动态关系确实立刻就发生了变化。
And it's fraud.
而且充满了暗潮汹涌。
It's very fraud.
非常暗潮汹涌。
I thought you played it great.
我觉得你演得太棒了。
Just the, I'm not ready.
就是那种“我还没准备好”。
I'm not ready.
“我还没准备好”。
The calm guy all walks in.
那个冷静的家伙走进来。
Okay, I'm ready.
好吧，我准备好了。
I mean, game on.
我的意思是，比赛开始了。
I got to get back out there with Barney.
我得和巴尼一起重新回到那种生活。
I've got to like get, got to hook up with whoever I possibly can.
我得去跟尽可能多的任何人发生关系。
And that's what happens.
事实也确实如此。
It's such a human thing to, you know, to wanna win the breakup to be the more okay person.
想要在分手里“获胜”，想成为表现得更无所谓的那个人，这真的是太人性化的心理了。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, to have landed on your feet the best.
你知道的，就是想表现得自己落地最稳、状态最好。
And the second you wanna prove that it's ruined.
但只要你一想去证明这一点，就全毁了。
You're not achieving it, the second you're trying to prove it.
只要你试图去证明，你就已经输了。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Rebecca, we were watching, one of our hardest laps of the episode was the, okay, I'm ready.
丽贝卡，我们看的时候，这一集里让我们笑得最大声的片段之一就是“好吧，我准备好了”。
And I think it was because it's so, just so human.
我想这是因为这太真实、太人性化了。
It's like, you played that so great, We're watching a whole summer go by.
就像是你演得太棒了，我们看着一整个夏天就这么过去。
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm ready.
我很好，我很好，我很好，我准备好了。
And it felt like the starting gun is fired of this race we're gonna see.
这就感觉像是我们即将看到的这场竞赛的发令枪终于响了。
Who's gonna win the breakup?
谁能在分手战中获胜？
And of course, in the end, it's nobody, and Robin's not even trying to win the breakup.
当然，到头来谁也没赢，罗宾甚至都没打算在分手战中赢。
And she was much more hurt and had a much harder time than Ted knew, and thank God she admitted that to Ted in the end, and that's what keeps them friends.
而且她受到的伤害比泰德知道的要深得多，也艰难得多，谢天谢地她最后向泰德承认了这一点，这也是他们能维持朋友关系的原因。
We'll get there, but the scene with Ted and Robin at her apartment door is actually weirdly one of my favorite Ted and Robin scenes.
我们待会儿会聊到那儿，但泰德和罗宾在她公寓门口的那场戏，其实奇怪地成为了我最喜欢的泰德和罗宾的对手戏之一。
Like I think it's so like spunky and funny and like it feels like they know each other really well by that point It's you know what I mean?
我觉得它非常有活力、非常搞笑，而且感觉他们到那个时候对彼此已经非常了解了，你知道我的意思吗？
There's there's there's no bullshit.
里面没有任何废话。
I love that scene too I want to hear what that felt like although I keep thinking about New York actual Mapping and I'm like who just darts down the Brooklyn from the Upper West you can't get over that one You can't get over that one.
我也很喜欢那场戏，我想听听那是什么感觉，虽然我一直在想纽约的实际地图，我就在想，谁会从上西区直接冲到布鲁克林呢，你没法接受这个设定，你没法接受这个。
You're like it's too fucking far.
你会觉得这他妈太远了。
You're in 10 really bothers you because you live in Brooklyn now.
你在第十季里真的很纠结，因为你现在住在布鲁克林。
So you're really you're in Team Brooklyn.
所以你真的是布鲁克林战队的。
When you live in Brooklyn, a trip to Manhattan is like, okay, get the covered wagon.
当你住在布鲁克林时，去一趟曼哈顿就像是，好吧，去把大篷车弄来。
The covered wagon, we're making a trip to Manhattan.
大篷车，我们要去曼哈顿了。
We'll have to stop and make baked beans overnight.
我们还得停下来，花一晚上烤焗豆。
Yeah, it's impossible to get to Manhattan.
对啊，去曼哈顿简直难于上青天。
The cow will go to the bathroom.
牛都要去上厕所了。
Yeah, it is.
对啊，确实。
It's a frickin' hike.
这简直是一次他妈的长途跋涉。
But yes, let's get to that scene.
不过是的，我们来聊聊那场戏吧。
The other thing that I wanted to point out, the butterfly tattoo, you had a lot of beard stunts and then you had like a tattoo stuff.
我想指出的另一件事，那个蝴蝶纹身，你有很多胡子的特技，然后你还有纹身之类的。
Like this is a very, your body went through a lot in this episode, that's S.
就像这个，你的身体在这集里经历了很多，太疯狂了。
B is yet again, the thing you think would just be completely made up, isn't entirely made up.
B组又来了，你觉得完全是编出来的事情，其实并非完全虚构。
Dave Hemmingsen, who became a writer on Hemmium season three, who's a great writer, he went on many years later to write the movie, The Holdovers, by a great movie.
戴夫·海明森，他后来成了第三季的编剧，是个非常优秀的编剧，他很多年后去写了电影《留校联盟》，一部很棒的电影。
Great movie.
很棒的电影。
It's a great movie.
这是一部很棒的电影。
Dave Hemingson, Hemi, very funny.
戴夫·海明森，海米，非常搞笑。
He was a little...
他以前有点……
I remember law school grad, wasn't he?
我记得他是法学院毕业的，对吧？
But he's a lawyer.
但他是个律师。
He had been a lawyer.
他以前当过律师。
Yeah, he's a really smart dude.
对，他是个非常聪明家伙。
And he wrote for Hemiim for season three.
他为第三季写过剧本。
And he, we were trying to think of like, what can Ted do, you know, to...
然后他，我们在想，泰德能做点什么，你知道的，为了……
What insane night does Ted have and what does he wake up with the next morning?
泰德度过了怎样疯狂的一夜，第二天早上醒来时他身上有什么？
I guess it's a little pineapple incident.
我想这有点像菠萝事件。
But Hemingson said, okay, not long ago, I was on the beach in Venice.
但海明森说，好吧，不久前，我在威尼斯的沙滩上。
I think maybe he lived in Venice Beach.
我想他可能住在威尼斯海滩。
and like a bare-chested muscular, like macho-looking guy, ran by me, says Hemi.
然后一个赤裸着上身、肌肉发达、看起来很有男子气概的家伙从我身边跑过，海米说。
And we sort of watched him go, my wife and I, my wife is probably looking at him, I got guys pretty hot.
我们有点看着他走远，我和我妻子，我妻子可能在看着他，心想这哥们挺性感的。
And as he ran past us, and we saw the back of him, there was a butterfly tattoo, right, where Ted winds up getting a butterfly tattoo.
当他从我们身边跑过时，我们看到了他的背面，那里有一个蝴蝶纹身，正好就是泰德后来纹蝴蝶纹身的位置。
And it just stuck in Heming since he had knew that, he was like, Ted should get a butterfly tattooed in the tramp stamp positioning, and we did it.
这事儿一直在海明森脑子里挥之不去，他知道这个，他就觉得，泰德应该在下背部的那个位置纹一个蝴蝶，然后我们就这么拍了。
I remember being like, we can't do that, but then we did it.
我记得当时觉得，我们不能这么做，但后来我们还是照做了。
It's funny to consider like, you never know when you're being observed by a comedy writer.
一想到你永远不知道什么时候会被一个喜剧编剧观察，就觉得挺搞笑的。
Like, does that guy know?
就像，那家伙知道吗？
Did that guy see it ever on TV and go?
那家伙有没有在电视上看到过然后想：
That's, could that, could I have inspired that?
那是……这会不会是我引发的灵感？
Also, I, it was the first time, and maybe I just was not, I don't know, maybe I don't know things, but I think that was the first time I heard the term tramp.
还有，这是我第一次听到“tramp（荡妇印记/下背部纹身）”这个词，也许是我孤陋寡闻，我不知道，也许我就是懂得少，但我觉得那是第一次听到这个词。
It was, it was for me.
对我来说是这样的。
And maybe it was Hemmingson who said that when he was telling that story.
也许是海明森在讲那个故事时说出来的。
And where I feel like multiple people in the room were like, what now?
当时我觉得房间里的好几个人都在想：什么东西？
What are you talking about?
你在说什么呢？
I had not entered the cultural lexicon.
我还没能进入文化词汇表。
Like it's pretty universally accepted.
就像这是被普遍接受的一样。
That's what we definitely do.
我们确实是这么做的。
We didn't invent it, but we definitely boosted that.
我们没有发明它，但我们绝对推波助澜了。
We amplified it.
我们放大了它。
We amplified that.
我们放大了那个。
And cougar too, I think.
还有美洲狮老女人，我觉得也是。
Cougar, yeah.
美洲狮，对。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
It's funny how terms that get so, that permeate, when you introduce them, it's like, It's a big drum roll and it actually looks weird when you look back.
真搞笑，那些深入人心的词汇，当你引入它们的时候，就像是，伴随着隆重的鼓点，而当你回看时，其实感觉怪怪的。
You're like, wait, that was actually the introduction or I thought it was.
你会想，等等，那真的是它的登场吗，还是我以为那是。
I thought the same thing watching this last night.
我昨晚看这个的时候也有同感。
I was like, I definitely had not heard that for any of the other euphemisms for it.
我想，对于其他那些委婉说法，我绝对没听过。
That like, I think we were like just using the internet to look them up.
就像，我觉得我们当时只是在用网上去查它们。
I think a couple of people in the room were like, what are you talking about?
我觉得房间里有几个人当时就像是在说，你在说什么呢？
You know, Panama City license plate.
你知道的，巴拿马城车牌。
We're like, what the fuck are you talking about?
我们就想，他妈的你在说什么呢？
Like, a couple of people knew these.
就像，有几个人知道这些。
I'm like, you're actively everyone's supposed to know this.
我就想，你明明在带头让所有人觉得大家都该知道这个。
I've never heard of this.
我从来没听说过这个。
but it was great.
但它真的很棒。
I always think it's funny that like, in just like a couple years, like Ted gets massively blackout drunk and wakes up multiple times of what has gone on and no one pulls him aside and is like, buddy.
我总是觉得很好笑，在短短几年里，比如泰德喝到彻底断片，多次醒来都不知道发生了什么，竟然没有人把他拉到一边说，老兄。
I know.
我知道。
It's because I had stopped drinking that summer, but like, why doesn't someone, like- It's concerning.
那是因为我那年夏天刚戒酒，但是，为什么就没人——这太让人担心了。
And they have an intervention banner just sitting there.
而且他们明明就备好了一条干预横幅放在那儿。
They never do an intervention for drinking.
他们从来不为酗酒搞干预。
They only do interventions for non-drinking things.
他们只为那些不喝酒的事情搞干预。
It's just like, stop wearing those crocs.
比如，别再穿那种洞洞鞋了。
Let's go get drunk.
咱们去喝一杯吧。
It's not, yeah, you know, they could have, at least one time, like, that's a lot of blackouts.
也不是，对吧，你知道的，他们本可以，至少有一次，比如，那可是好几次断片。
That's actually quite, like it's true.
其实真的是这样，可以说是。
It's a lot of blackouts with real consequences.
那是伴随着现实后果的好几次断片。
Like a potentially dead woman in your bed.
比如你床上可能躺着个死女人。
Tattooed.
还有纹身。
You know what?
你知道吗？
It was funny how much the tattoo was dropped in the end of the episode, and it does come back.
搞笑的是，这集结尾时这个纹身被一笔带过了，但它后面还会出现。
It's a whole storyline later.
这后来成了一条完整的故事线。
Getting rid of this tattoo.
洗掉这个纹身。
But I will say I love the episode, but in the end of the episode, I really wanted us to have written a scene where they're like, what the fuck are we going to do about this tattoo, Ted?
不过我要说我很喜欢这一集，但在这一集结尾，我真的很希望我们能写一场戏，他们说，泰德，我们他妈的到底该拿这个纹身怎么办？
Like, this has got to come off of you.
这玩意儿必须得从你身上弄下来。
Like, the fact that we just dropped it.
就像，我们怎么就这么轻描淡写地略过了。
And now it's just like 10, Robin, are working this thing out.
现在变成泰德和罗宾在解决这事儿。
Ted's got a fucking butterfly above his ass.
泰德屁股上方却他妈纹着个蝴蝶。
This is a real problem.
这可是个大问题。
But I love that line of just hung over Ted's irrationally trying to like use water on it as if that's going to get it out.
但我很喜欢那个情节，宿醉的泰德异想天开地想用水去洗掉它，好像那样就能洗掉似的。
and Marshall's like, you might want to try some club soda.
然后玛修说，你或许可以试试苏打水。
That's not, I really, that line.
那不是，我真的很喜欢那句台词。
You know what else maybe left though, when you see the like writers trying to do a hard turn into a transition.
你知道可能还留下了什么吗，当你看到编剧们试图硬生生地转场时。
Yes.
对。
I mean, he says, I need some ointment or something.
我是说，他说，我需要点药膏什么的。
That is a thing with line.
台词里就是有这么个东西。
I do think I sold that as well as you could possibly do it.
我觉得我把那句台词演绎得不能再好了。
You know what it is, it's all the circuits are jammed.
你知道是怎么回事，所有线路都占线了。
It's all the circuits are jammed.
所有线路都占线了。
That's exactly right.
完全正确。
Why did I always get those lines?
为什么我总能分到那种台词？
I don't know, but I'm really sorry because it's a thankless job to have to say all the circuits are jammed or I need some ointment.
我不知道，但我真的很抱歉，因为说“所有线路都占线”或者“我需要点药膏”真是个吃力不讨好的活儿。
I need some ointment or something.
我需要点药膏什么的。
And then it's like, wait a minute, Spanish, massage oil or whatever that was.
然后就变成，等一下，西班牙语，按摩油还是别的什么。
That was clunky.
那段太生硬了。
That was sweaty, as we said.
正如我们所说，那段拍得满头大汗。
But I'll tell you, she's up, something so funny.
但我跟你说，她笑得，太逗了。
Jordana was laughing so hard at everyone just falling for Gaille.
乔丹娜笑得前仰后合，因为大家都落入了盖尔的圈套。
And when you went on seagulls.
还有你演海鸥的那段。
That seagull land.
那片海鸥禁地。
Is that a meme?
那是Meme（表情包/梗）吗？
I feel like that's a meme.
我觉得那绝对是个梗。
People mean that all the time, just that shot, and it ends on seagull, and people, yeah, it is so fucking funny.
大家总是拿这个开玩笑，就那个镜头，最后定格在海鸥身上，然后大家，对，真的太特么搞笑了。
Pam Fryman, perfect, perfectly timed, perfectly directed.
帕姆·弗赖曼，绝了，时机完美，导演得也完美。
A great pan, yeah, a pan-fryman.
一个绝妙的摇镜头（pan），对，帕姆·弗赖曼（Pan-Fryman）。
A pan-fryman, it was a pan-fryman.
一个帕姆·弗赖曼，这就是个帕姆·弗赖曼。
Why did you say that?
你为什么要这么说？
We really shouldn't.
我们真的不该这样的。
We should've.
我们本来应该的。
Jason had such an ability to commit to ridiculousness.
杰森有一种全身心投入荒诞剧情的能力。
I was thinking the same thing, he's just God bless him.
我也这么觉得，上帝保佑他。
He just looked like he never was trying to preserve his, like, I'm, like, he just, he had no pride about it.
他看起来从不试图维护自己，就好像，他完全没有偶像包袱。
I really find it impressive.
我真的觉得这太厉害了。
Like he, he, he did the most ridiculous things with the most gusto.
他总是以最大的热情去做最荒谬的事情。
A hundred million percent all the time.
百分之百，随时随地。
Like he just, he knew, he just, he is the epitome of he knew the assignment.
他就是那种人，他完美诠释了什么叫“懂得都懂”。
You know, he is a walking, he knew the assignment.
你知道的，他简直就是“懂得都懂”的活生生的例子。
He's just like, this is the bit, I know what the bit is.
他就像是，这就是个包袱，我知道这个包袱是什么。
I'm doing it.
我在演呢。
And he, when he tucks down below that pillow where the pillow is covering his mouth and just his little eyes are looking up, it's just so fucking funny.
当他把头缩到枕头底下，枕头遮住嘴巴，只露出小眼睛往上看的时候，真的太特么搞笑了。
And that's all like him.
这全都是他自己发挥的。
I don't remember in the script it said he's hugging a pillow.
我不记得剧本里写了让他抱着一个枕头。
Like I think that's what Jason found.
我觉得那是杰森自己想出来的。
And he found it.
而且是他自己挖掘出来的。
And also like, he turns away from the camera like he can't believe how much feeling he's feeling.
还有，他背过身去面对镜头，好像不敢相信自己内心的情绪有这么汹涌。
He's got like a little like, it's so funny.
他还有点那样的小动作，太搞笑了。
It was really funny.
真的超级搞笑。
And we had two pop, two big pop stars in one episode which was not really the planet just sort of happened And Ricky Iglesias had been pitched to us, I think.
而且我们一集里有两个大流行巨星，这在当时并不常见，算是阴差阳错吧，恩里克·伊格莱西亚斯好像是别人向我们推荐的。
CBS liked him, let's get him on.
哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）喜欢他，就让他来演吧。
And I think Manny Moore happened after that.
曼迪·摩尔好像就是在那之后定下来的。
It was kind of like, oh, wait, we just, we just stumbled into two pretty significant pop stars.
就好像是，哦，等等，我们稀里糊涂就请到了两位相当有分量的流行巨星。
An incredible run of pop stars on how we met with other, like, right?
我们在《老爸老妈浪漫史》里请过一串不可思议的流行巨星，对吧？
Well, George Clinton.
对，还有乔治·克林顿。
Well, George Clinton began.
对，乔治·克林顿开了个头。
But yeah, I was thinking the same thing.
不过对，我也正这么想呢。
We're not, you know, we're only a few weeks, few short weeks away from Britney Spears at this point, too.
而且你知道吗，距离小甜甜布兰妮登场也就只有几周，短短几周时间了。
Oh, one other thing I wanted to say about Gail, that I thought was really funny, is the characters on the show are, they're all like pretty heady people, right?
哦，关于盖尔我还有一件事想说，我觉得特别搞笑，那就是剧中的角色们，他们都挺有文化内涵的，对吧？
Like they're brainiacs, they went to college, they're, they sit around a booth drinking and making each other laugh with words, right?
就像他们都是高智商，上过大学，然后他们，他们坐在卡座里喝酒，用言语逗彼此开心，对吧？
They're, there's a cerebral quality to their reparté.
他们，他们的即兴问答有一种脑力激荡的特质。
Yeah.
对。
And then this guy from Argentina comes in and he like puts them in their bodies.
然后这个来自阿根廷的家伙进来了，他就像是让他们感受到了自己的身体。
like puts them in their senses, right?
就像让他们唤醒了感官，对吧？
And Marshall, Lily, and Robin are all like, absolutely like, when, you know, when you're led out of your body, like out of your mind and into your body, it's quite pleasurable because you forget you have one.
马修、莉莉和罗宾都觉得，绝对是这样的，当你知道，当你被引导着离开紧绷的思维，进入到身体里时，这其实非常愉悦，因为你都忘了自己还有个身体。
Yeah.
对。
You know, you're like, oh my God, like.
你知道的，你会觉得，哦天哪，就像。
He unlocked something for them.
他为他们开启了某种新体验。
Yeah, he unlocked something like, they're tasting food and they're actually tasting it.
对，他开启了某种，他们开始品尝食物，而且是真的在品尝。
He takes them out of their autopilot.
他把他们从自动驾驶状态中拉了出来。
So I don't want to shit totally on Guy L.
所以我不想把盖尔贬得一无是处。
Like, Guy L.
就像，盖尔这个人。
There's something to him.
他身上还是有点东西的。
He has something to him.
他确实有两下子。
He's in the moment.
他很活在当下。
And on vacation, it must have been absolutely magical.
而且在度假的时候，这绝对会非常神奇。
Yes.
是的。
Well, that's, and then that's what episode two is about.
嗯，那就是，然后第二集讲的就是这个。
That's what our next episode of season three is about.
这就是我们第三季下一集要讨论的内容。
But can you transport that back?
但你能把这种状态带回日常生活吗？
Yeah, Ali really made me laugh when she gets embarrassed and she says, I do not shut up.
对，艾莉真的把我逗笑了，当她感到尴尬时，她说，我才没有喋喋不休呢。
Oh my God.
哦天哪。
Yeah.
对。
That was, that was, that was about guy.
那是，那是，那是关于那个家伙的。
It was about you laugh at everything he says or whatever.
就是关于你对他说的一切都觉得好笑之类的。
Yeah.
对。
Do you know what else is really funny is is Marshall, like the guy's accredited, but he has a laminated he checks out.
你知道还有什么特别搞笑的吗，就是马修，那家伙虽然有资质认证，但他拿出了一个塑封的……
He's in his cart, I think, damn it, he checks out.
他掏出卡片时，我心想，该死，他过关了。
It's laminated, only a professional can have, the like an achievable emanation.
那是塑封的，只有专业人士才能拥有，就像某种可望而不可即的身份证明。
Yeah, yeah, that was really funny.
对，对，那个真的超级搞笑。
It's like the thing about, I think we talked about this, but like you can go in, anyone will let you into any building if you're carrying a clipboard.
这就好比，我想我们之前讨论过这个，只要你拿着一个剪贴板，任何人都会放你进任何大楼。
Like there are certain like signifiers of like, I'm official.
就像有一些特定的标志，代表着“我是官方人员”。
Yeah, or wearing the lanyard.
对，或者是挂着工作证挂绳。
I think wearing a lanyard will really get you anywhere, but that's kind of a lamin, that's a lamination, like the necklace thing with the laminated, like it doesn't even matter what's in the laminated thing, but I guess that's a lamination, you gotta get a lamination will get you in anywhere.
我觉得挂个工作证挂绳真的能让你去任何地方，但那种塑封卡，就像挂在脖子上的那个带塑封的东西，虽然塑封里面到底是什么甚至都不重要，但我想这就是塑封的力量，你只要弄个塑封证件就能畅通无阻。
What's the, I don't we have the old ref, old tech, we have all those terms?
那个什么来着，我不知道我们是不是在用那个老梗，老科技，我们有所有这些术语？
Yeah.
对。
There's certain, just wardrobe choices, when Ted walks in in that Western shirt for his big doubt.
有一些，纯粹是服装选择上的问题，当泰德穿着那件西部衬衫去完成他的重大搭讪时。
That bothered me a lot.
这让我觉得很烦躁。
I said that, I said that out loud.
我当时把这话直接说出来了。
I was like, what is happening with that shirt?
我当时就想，那件衬衫到底是怎么回事？
There was a weird quasi-western moment in where Joe pretended.
剧中出现了一个奇怪的准西部风格时刻，乔曾假装过。
That would be Old West, like that.
那会是老西部风格，就像那样。
The Old West, yes, it was the Old West.
老西部，是的，那就是老西部。
And what, I guess it was mirroring that that was kind of happening, but it really stood out to me.
而且什么，我猜这可能是在呼应当时那种流行趋势，但这真的很显眼。
And I even found myself thinking like, was that really happening that much in real life?
我甚至发现自己在想，现实生活中真的有那末多人那样穿吗？
It was also like, I tried to pass off as like, yeah, I just threw this on.
而且这感觉就像是，我试图伪装成，“哦，这件衣服我是随手套上的。”
Yeah, oh my God, that was a rough one.
对，哦天哪，那套造型太灾难了。
I mean, you're supposed to go by and have like a bad decision.
我是说，你本来应该去偶遇然后做出一个糟糕的决定。
Would he truly have ended up kissing Mandy Moore in that shirt?
他真的会穿着那件衬衫去和曼迪·摩尔接吻吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
After three seconds, he meets her and three seconds later, he's like, yeah, she's like, I love that cowboy shirt.
才三秒钟，他刚遇到她，三秒钟后，他就像是，她甚至还说，我喜欢那件牛仔衬衫。
I really liked her Amy's Burns to Barney.
我真的很喜欢艾米对巴尼的那些毒舌吐槽。
Yeah.
对。
Although it's great when he calls her Tommy Lee, which I thought was funny.
不过当他叫她汤米·李时真的很搞笑，我觉得那段挺有意思的。
But yeah, her burns to him are, again, like we've kind of been tracking this, like Barney needs the piss taken out of him with some regularity in the show.
但说真的，她对他的吐槽——就像我们之前一直在关注的——巴尼在这部剧里确实需要经常被杀杀威风。
Yes, with frequency, great frequency.
是的，经常如此，频率极高。
And also that thing of Barney, as much as he talks about wanting to get laid all the time, his tribe is often just wanting Ted's attention.
还有就是巴尼的那种心态，尽管他嘴上总是说想要随时随地泡妞，但他真正的小团体往往只是想吸引泰德的注意力。
And this is the end of the time he hates the Ted's attention.
而这也是他极其讨厌泰德获得注意力的时候。
Cause he's like, we were gonna go, this was wingman reborn.
因为他会想，我们本来要去的，这是僚机重振雄风的时刻。
But this is us back out of the town.
结果我们这是又退出了。
You're already, what's somebody now?
你现在怎么又跟别人好上了？
Are you supposed to blow up?
你难道不该跟我一起大显身手吗？
It's like the pursuit of women and sex is almost like, it could be anything.
这就好比，对女性和性的追求几乎成了借口，换成什么都行。
Like if Ted said, let's play laser tag, He'd be like, great.
就像如果泰德说，我们去玩激光枪战吧，他也会说，太棒了。
It's just a way for them to spotlight their focus on something that they can do together.
这只是他们将注意力集中在某项可以一起做的事情上的一种方式。
Yes.
没错。
Well, it's like, this is not my observation, but male friendships are often based on doing something.
嗯，这就好比——这不是我的原创观察——男性的友谊通常是基于“一起做点什么”。
We've got to do something.
我们得做点什么。
We've got to make something together.
我们得一起创造点什么。
Here we are.
我们现在就在这儿。
We're all friends, Alex, Josh, and Craig.
我们都是朋友，亚历克斯、乔什和克雷格。
We're making this podcast.
我们在做这个播客。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
It makes you hang out and bond to make a thing.
通过一起做一个项目，能促进你们聚在一起并建立羁绊。
As a guy.
作为男人。
Did you ever hear that thing?
你听过那个说法吗？
I can never remember what I've said in the previous episodes, But there's that thing that women have like chest to chest friendships and that they face each other and say things to each other.
我永远记不清我在前几集里都说过什么，但有这么个说法：女性拥有的是“面对面”的友谊，她们会面对面地看着对方，向彼此倾诉心事。
And men have shoulder to shoulder friendships where they like sit in a bar and watch, or watch books together, or, you know.
而男性拥有的是“肩并肩”的友谊，他们会一起坐在酒吧里看着某样东西，或者一起看球赛，或者别的什么。
You have to be doing a thing.
你们必须得正在一起干点什么。
And for Tenemore, Barney wants to be out on the hunt.
至于泰德和巴尼，巴尼想要出去猎艳。
He doesn't want them either of them to succeed necessarily because then they won't be hanging out anymore.
他其实不一定希望他们俩中的任何一个成功，因为如果成功了，他们就不用再一起鬼混了。
He just wants to be together for a while before success.
他只是想在成功到来之前，大家聚在一起过一段日子。
It doesn't matter if success happens.
成功会不会发生根本不重要。
And then at the end, when the offer of sax, he's kind of like, yeah, okay.
然后到最后，当真的有艳遇的机会摆在眼前时，他的反应却是，好吧，行吧。
Yeah, right.
对，没错。
I guess it's good.
我想这样也挺好。
Okay, fine.
好吧，行吧。
Now the Ted's gone.
现在泰德走了。
What's that as well?
那又怎么样呢？
There was.
还有。
I remember that hot tub thing was so funny, though.
不过我记得那个热浴缸的桥段真的太搞笑了。
What's Barney's line like, Ted has a classic, you know, style, never goes out of style.
巴尼是怎么说的来着，泰德有一种经典的风格，永不过时。
And ever green cuts, never goes out of style season to season burn.
还有那些常青的经典剪裁，历经数季也永不过时的吐槽。
It's just like this lovely compliment of Ted's look, but it's as a burr.
这就像是泰德这个造型的一个可爱夸奖，但却是个刺。
Yeah, it's that was really funny That's a really weird for someone who had spent, you know 44 episodes criticizing his sartorial choices.
对，这真的很好笑，对于一个花了两季也就是44集来批判他穿衣品味的人来说，这真的很奇怪。
He really actually respects them and on an evening where he's wearing a stupid fucking cow By sure to know this.
他其实真的很尊重这些，而在这样一个他穿着一件愚蠢透顶的衬衫的夜晚，一定要注意这一点。
This is the one evening Ted didn't have the evergreen classic Loki's And now commercials, end of commercials, back to show.
这是泰德唯一一个没有经典永流传的插曲的夜晚，现在是广告时间，广告结束，回到节目。
I did love getting drunker and drunker is always fun.
我确实很喜欢越喝越醉，这总是很有趣。
And dark, dark, Ted, it was fun to see you go a little dark.
而且还有黑暗、阴暗面的泰德，看到你变得有点腹黑其实挺好玩的。
This was not Ted trying to have a magical night where he's going to meet the mother.
这可不是泰德想要度过一个要去遇见妈妈的神奇夜晚。
This was Ted wanting to have meaning of sex, to win a breakup with Robin who had a really hot boyfriend.
这是泰德想要通过有意义的性爱，在与一个有着超级性感男友的罗宾的分手中扳回一城。
Well, this leads to a larger question that I have for you.
好吧，这就引出了我要问你的一个更宏大的问题。
So I remember at the end of season two, you and Carter came to me and said, you know, we've had Ted be like hunting, you know, pining for Rob and wanting to be in a relationship, always thinking about relationships.
所以记得在第二季结束时，你和卡特来找我，说你知道的，我们让泰德一直在寻找，你知道的，对罗宾苦苦思念，想要谈恋爱，总是想着恋爱。
We want to take a little time with Ted where he's just out with Barney on the prowl.
我们想在泰德身上花点时间，让他只是和巴尼一起出去寻欢作乐。
Yes.
没错。
Remember that?
还记得吗？
Yes.
记得。
And I remember you guys were flexing these new kind of muscles with Ted.
我记得你们当时在泰德身上尝试展现这种全新的特质。
I loved this.
我很喜欢这样。
Like I thought it was really fun not to be like the moony eyed relationship guy.
比如我觉得不用总是扮演那个满眼深情的恋爱脑男生，这真的很有趣。
Yeah.
对。
Remember, Pam told me, maybe, maybe you guys told me, that the network was like, hold up.
还记得帕姆告诉过我，也许，也许你们告诉过我，电视台的反应是：等等。
Right.
没错。
Hold up.
等等。
Maybe a little.
也许稍微。
And I remember what Pam said to me was the network said, there's a lot of Barney's on TV.
我记得帕姆对我说的是，电视台说，电视上有太多巴尼了。
And I don't mean to flatten out what Neil was doing, which was a very special meaning.
我不是在贬低尼尔所做的事，那是非常特别的诠释。
There were a lot of cads on TV.
电视上有很多花花公子。
There were a lot of guys who were like, just wanted to get laid.
有很多那种只想上床的家伙。
Yeah.
对。
There's only one Ted.
但只有一个泰德。
Right.
没错。
Like they knew that he was like a special kind of creature.
就像他们知道他是一种特别的存在。
Yes.
是的。
Like in his DNA.
就像刻在他的基因里。
And they, I think, went to you and said, can you please bring him back to his kind of original five or sevens.
我想他们当时找到你们，说：能请把他带回他原本那种前五集或前七集的设定吗？
Yeah, that may have been a little later in his, cause there's a few moments in season three where Ted is dark.
对，那可能在他经历的稍后阶段吧，因为在第三季里有几个时刻，泰德变得挺黑暗的。
Ted's on a bit of a dark spiral.
泰德陷入了一点点黑暗的堕落旋涡。
There's this episode, no tomorrow.
有这一集《没有明天》。
There's, there's some episodes where he is not his best Ted.
还有一些集里，他并不是状态最好的泰德。
And I think that's what's interesting.
而我认为这正是引人入胜的地方。
I think it's interesting to show that.
我认为展现这一点很有意思。
But it's the same tug of war about the network wanting, you know, CBS didn't always get how much we wanted to shake up the show.
但这其实是关于电视台诉求的拉锯战，CBS并不总是理解我们有多么想在剧中做出震撼的改变。
along the way and the serialized way and show that we're going to do a whole arc where Ted is not the moony-eyed rom-com guy and that rattled them a little bit, I think as I recall.
沿着这条路以这种连贯序列的方式展现我们要拍一整条故事线，让泰德不再是那个满眼深情的浪漫喜剧男主角，据我回忆，这确实让他们有点慌乱。
Yeah.
对。
Well, I think it's in some ways it's like, that's not the show we bought.
嗯，我觉得在某种程度上就像是，这不是我们买下的那个节目。
We bought the show about this guy.
我们买的是关于这个男人的节目。
But we said it's a show about growing up and evolution and the chapters you go through and you're not always the same guy and you're not always the best guy, none of us are.
但我们说过，这是一个关于成长、演变以及你所经历的人生阶段的节目，你不可能永远是同一个人，你也不可能永远是最好的人，我们谁都不是。
Did we talk?
我们聊过吗？
No, remind me.
没有，提醒我一下。
because I have a small child at home, my brain.
因为家里有个小孩，我的大脑。
It's a little fried.
有点烧糊涂了。
But did you, did we talk about that thing about how choices are either hats, haircuts, or tattoos?
但是你，我们讨论过那个关于选择要么是帽子、发型还是纹身的事情吗？
I can't remember either, so say it again, because it's good.
我也记不清了，所以再说一遍吧，因为这个观点很好。
Okay.
好吧。
So this is hilarious because this episode involves a tattoo.
所以这非常搞笑，因为这一集涉及到一个纹身。
Yeah.
对。
But I think James Clear might have said something like this who wrote atomic habits, but the idea is all decisions are either hats, haircuts, or tattoos.
但我想写《原子习惯》的詹姆斯·克利尔可能说过类似的话，这个想法就是：所有的决定要么是帽子、发型，要么是纹身。
Hats are, you try it on, eh, I don't like this, you take it off, very little consequence to that decision.
帽子就像是，你试戴一下，呃，我不喜欢这个，你把它摘下来，这个决定带来的后果非常小。
A haircut decision is, okay, longer tail of consequence, but it'll grow back, right?
发型的决定是，好吧，后果的影响时间会更长一点，但它会再长出来的，对吧？
Like eventually it'll grow back.
就像最终它会再长出来一样。
A tattoo is a tattoo, you know?
纹身就是纹身，你知道的？
A tattoo is like, it's there, like you're inked, you know?
纹身就像是，它就呆在那儿，就像你被永久印上了标记，你知道的？
It's like, and it feels like, how are my mother, especially in the 20s era, we're still in, you know, they're now 29, right?
就像是，感觉我的母亲，尤其是在我们现在仍身处的20岁年龄段，你知道的，他们现在29岁了，对吧？
Something like that.
差不多吧。
Yeah, like, you're still trying on hats, right?
对，就像，你还在试戴帽子，对吧？
Like you're still, oh, this is just one night, this is just like whatever, but it's funny because Ted gets a tattoo, Marshall gets a terrible haircut, and covers it up with a hat.
就像你还在，哦，这只是一夜情，这只是随便怎样，但这就很搞笑，因为泰德去纹了个身，马歇尔剪了个糟糕的发型，然后用一顶帽子把它盖住。
All of these happen, it's true, yeah, yeah.
这些事情都发生了，确实，对，对。
But I think it's an interesting framework to look at decisions, basically, like, when people in their 20s ask me, you know, for advice or whatever, and I'm like, just, you know, it's like, try on some hats, like try on some different, see what feels good to you because if you're careful and not reckless, like your decisions are like, you can just try on another hat, you know?
但我觉得这是一个看待决定的很有趣的框架，基本上就是，当20多岁的人向我征求建议或什么的，我就会说，你就，你知道的，就像，试戴几顶不同的帽子，看看什么感觉对你来说最舒服，因为如果你小心谨慎而不是鲁莽行事，你的决定就像是，你随时可以换一顶帽子试试，你知道的？
But then you get older and I think going from hat to hat, like living a hat to hat lifestyle like in your 40s and 50s gets really, like if you haven't made some real decisions and put down some roots and made some real, you know, depth-centered decisions and forge relationships that can get a little sadder.
但后来你变老了，我觉得在40多岁和50多岁的时候，如果一直过着帽子换帽子、帽子到帽子这样飘忽不定的生活，就会变得真的很——如果你没有做出一些真正的决定并扎下一些根基，没有做出一些以深度为核心的决定并建立起能够维系的恋爱关系，情况就会变得有点凄凉。
Yeah, yeah, I agree.
对，对，我同意。
And it's interesting that Ted literally gets a tattoo.
而且有趣的是，泰德真的去纹了个身。
This is the perfect metaphor.
这真的是完美的隐喻。
Even if we've said this before, this is the perfect.
就算我们以前说过这个，这也是最完美的。
And he has this knight where he's not himself.
而且他度过了这样一个他不再是自己的夜晚。
He's not his best self.
他不是那个最好的自己。
His motivations are very impure.
他的动机非常不纯粹。
Not just trying to have a meaningless hookup, but like defying, winning the breakup, you know?
不仅仅是试图进行一次毫无意义的露水情缘，而是带有一种挑衅、在分手战中获胜的心态，你知道吗？
Like that's not a pure motivation.
这可不是一个纯粹的动机。
He wants to hurt Robin's feelings the way that his feelings have been hurt.
他想让罗宾感到难过，就像他自己的感情曾经受到伤害那样。
and he does have a consequence.
而他确实承担了后果。
He gets a tattoo, he's not a hat, it's a fucking tattoo.
他去纹了个身，这不是一顶帽子，这特么是个纹身。
Right, right.
对，对。
And it becomes a little mini arc.
而这变成了一个小小的迷你故事线。
I like that about this premiere.
我很喜欢这一集开场的这一点。
He has, there's a problem that has to be solved with this tattoo.
他遇到了一个必须通过这个纹身来解决的问题。
It does get us a trap as well.
这也让我们陷入了一个连环套。
We've talked about this before, but like, karma exists quite, it's a quite real force in how I met your mother universe.
我们以前讨论过这个，但在《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的宇宙中，因果报应确实存在，它是一股相当真实的强大陆量。
It is, yeah.
确实，对。
There are consequences to actions.
行为是有后果的。
I also love how Amy's boyfriend is Steve, the tattoo artist.
我也很喜欢艾米的男友是史蒂夫，那个纹身师。
And that guy, man.
那个家伙，天哪。
There are names also, Steve.
而且名字也是史蒂夫。
Yeah, that guy's fun.
对，那家伙很有趣。
You're names also, Steve.
你名字也是史蒂夫。
That guy was really well cast.
那个家伙选角真的太棒了。
But it's really fun to watch Marshall and Lily and Barney just like.
但看着马歇尔、莉莉和巴尼那种反应真的很有趣。
Trying to get Ted to say the word butterfly is very joy.
试图让泰德说出“蝴蝶”这个词充满了欢乐。
Trying to get.
试图让。
Neil did something that was so, when he first notices the tattoo, he did this thing where he kind of puts his whole, and tries to almost put his whole hand in his mouth.
尼尔做了一个动作，当他第一次注意到那个纹身时，他做了一个动作，他把整个，几乎试图把他的整个手塞进嘴里。
And I think, isn't that what Lenny and Squiggy is?
我想，那不就是雷尼和斯奎吉的动作吗？
I think that was Lenny and Shirley.
我觉得那是雷尼和雪莉的。
I do, yeah, that's, yeah.
我觉得是，对，就是那个，对。
Like they would like bite their hands and stuff.
就像他们会去咬自己的手之类的。
And I was like, Neil is doing like a Lenny and Squiggy reference, I think.
我就觉得，尼尔大概是在致敬伦尼和斯奎吉吧，我想。
I wonder if that was conscious.
我在想这到底是不是有意为之的。
I know we got to ask him that.
我知道我们得去问问他。
But it's also funny, like, what do you ask him to get on the top shelf, like?
但这也挺搞笑的，比如说，你让他拿高处的物件时会说些什么？
Oh, yeah, a fun new pot.
哦，对，一个有趣的新锅。
And then Marshall's just sitting there with a fun new pot, the rest of the scene.
然后马歇尔接下来的整场戏就只是坐在那儿，手里拿着一个有趣的新锅。
I didn't notice that.
我之前都没注意到。
I forgot it, I think.
我想我是给忘了吧。
Go back and look, he's just sitting there with it as they're trying to get Ted to say, but it's funny, like, like, Ted is just like, okay, I'll grab you the fondue pot.
回去看一眼，当他们试图让泰德开口时，他手里就一直拿着那玩意儿，但这就很好笑，就好比，泰德就说，好吧，我来帮你拿这个火锅。
Yeah, I was like, what?
对，我当时心想，什么？
I said that to her.
我对她说过这话。
That guy was like, why does Ted wouldn't Ted say, but why?
那家伙当时就说，泰德怎么会——泰德难道不该说“为什么吗”？
It's not in the morning.
现在又不是早上。
I also like when Marshall said, J crew catalog, who brings two golden retrievers to a canoe.
我也很喜欢马歇尔说的，J·克鲁（J. Crew）目录风，谁会带两只金毛寻回犬去划独木舟。
Yeah, that was a good little throw.
对，那是个挺不错的随性吐槽。
Ted has a line in that scene with Robin, where he goes Mr. Adore where he says, he's like the Cadillac of rebound guys.
泰德在和罗宾的那场戏里有一句台词，他说——哦，天哪，他说他就像是备胎界的凯迪拉克。
I have a dim memory that we were sponsored by Cadillac in this episode.
我隐约记得我们这一集是凯迪拉克赞助的。
Is that true?
真的吗？
Oh, fuck.
操。
I'm almost sure that's true.
我几乎可以肯定这是真的。
And that it was literally a product placement line that was as good a product placement line as could ever be.
而且那绝对是一句生硬的植入广告台词，不过它已经算是能做到的最好的植入广告台词了。
Do you know something?
你知道吗？
I think you're right.
我觉得你是对的。
And that's an amazing deep cut memory moment, Josh.
乔什，这真是一段了不起的深层记忆。
I forgot.
我都忘了。
I think I blocked that.
我想我是把这事给屏蔽了。
I blocked things like that.
我经常把这种事屏蔽掉。
If you got the original broadcast, you'd see a Cadillac commercial.
如果你看的是原版电视首播，你就会看到一个凯迪拉克广告。
You were a hundred percent right.
你百分之百没记错。
You're blowing my fucking mind right now.
你现在简直把我雷飞了。
I completely, I think I like really put, I filed these like soul crushing things back in some very deep file cabinet way in the back of my head.
我完全——我觉得我真的把这些让人灵魂破碎的东西，归档塞进了我脑海深处的一个档案柜里。
And it was true.
而且事实确实如此。
That's not what you want to remember.
这可不是你想记住的东西。
That's not what you want your sharpest memory to be.
这绝不是你想保留的那些最清晰的记忆。
I watched it go by when I watched the episode last night.
我昨晚看这一集的时候，看着它就这么播过去了。
And I thought, that's not really a joke.
我还心想，这其实根本不算个笑话。
It's kind of like a rebound guys.
就有点像是备胎什么的。
Like it's okay.
感觉就那样吧。
It's something, it's something I guess.
也就那么回事吧，我猜。
I feel like the word Cadillac is the best of the best.
我觉得“凯迪拉克”这个词就是同类里的天花板。
Yeah.
对。
Like that's what the, that's what the assumption is.
大家下意识就是这么认为的。
Yeah.
对。
It's not as bad as, can you get me some ointment or whatever, but it's not.
虽说没那么糟糕，不像“你能帮我拿点药膏来吗”之类的话，但它也确实……
I need some ointment or something.
我需要点药膏或者别的什么。
Oh, I think we're also sponsored by ointment.
哦，我想我们大概也受过药膏赞助吧。
I think that's why we did that one.
我觉得这就是我们当时拍那场戏的原因。
We'd know we'd sadly be voluntarily wrote the ointment line.
我们心知肚明，药膏那句台词绝对是我们自己心甘情愿写出来的。
Cadillac we were coerced into doing.
凯迪拉克那次我们才是被逼无奈。
That was it.
就是这样。
We had to say, I love that scene because you're right.
我们不得不那么说。我超喜欢那场戏，因为你说得对。
you can feel the history.
你能感受到那种历史感。
And the last time we saw them together, it's, I would have stolen you a whole orchestra, they're covered in red sauce from an Italian restaurant.
上一次我们看他们在一起时，那是句“我本愿意为你偷来整整一个乐团”，他们身上还沾着意大利餐厅的红酱。
They're hugging each other, it's so tragic.
他们紧紧相拥，太悲惨了。
And then, you know, Kobe's still got her kind of windswept Argentinian hair.
然后呢，你懂的，罗宾还留着那种被风吹乱的阿根廷风情发型。
And Ted's got his like, I just got tattooed and I'm probably still shaking off a hangover, but I'm filled with energy and I'm filled with passion.
而泰德则顶着一副——我刚去纹了个身，可能还没完全摆脱宿醉，但我充满了活力与激情。
And it's like, he doesn't go there to win her back.
就像是，他去那儿根本不是为了把她赢回来。
He goes there to say, I think this is like crappy of you to like parade this guy in front of my face, which then she says, that's not what I was doing.
他去那是为了说，我觉得你把这家伙大摇大摆地在我眼前晃来晃去，这事儿做得挺缺德的。然后罗宾就说，我才没这么做呢。
And it's very moving when she says, like, I cried for however long, like I couldn't, you know, I was trying to survive, what did she say I was trying to survive the breakup?
当她说出“我哭了多久多久，我甚至无法——你知道的，我当时只是在努力活下去”，她是怎么说的来着？我当时是在努力熬过分手吗？
I wasn't trying to win it, I was trying to survive it.
我不是在试图赢得这场分手，我只是在努力活过它。
Yes, I was trying to survive it.
没错，我是在努力熬过它。
Yeah, I was trying to survive it, which is actually very sweet.
对，我是在努力熬过它，其实这真的很温柔。
It's very sweet, she was hurt, she was in pain too, and he needed to hear that, you know?
非常温柔，她受了伤，她也很痛苦，而他当时确实需要听到这些，你知道吗？
He, that was a gift she gave him.
他——那是她送给他的一个礼物。
And also I do think one, I know I say, I never wrote anything, but I remember a tweak that I asked you guys if I could do, or maybe I said it in a run-through and then you guys liked it and actually changed it, where I said, oh, come on, he, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, he massages things, like I said, I'm pretty much talking things was my little tweet.
而且我也确实觉得，我知道我老说自己从来没写过什么，但我记得有一个微调是我问你们我能不能这么改的，或者可能我是在对词排练时随口一说，然后你们觉得挺好就直接改了——我说，“哦，得了吧，他，啦啦啦啦啦，他会按摩这按摩那的”，就像我说的，“我差不多是在瞎扯胡侃”，这就是我的小改动。
I think that's true.
我觉得确实是这样。
And I think you guys liked it and kept it.
而且我觉得你们当时挺喜欢并保留了它。
But I think it's also really great in that scene, by the way.
不过我觉得顺便说一句，那场戏里你的表现真的很棒。
You really did that scene great.
那场戏你演得真好。
And your energy of that was really, really interesting.
你在这场戏里展现出的能量真的非常非常有趣。
And it was not something we'd seen Ted do quite.
这并不是我们以前见泰德做过的常规操作。
It was an interesting ultimatum he was giving.
他当时抛出的最后通牒很有意思。
I think that's what I liked was I got to shift into a different gear.
我觉得我最喜欢的一点在于，我终于能切换到一个不同的档位了。
That wasn't like, love me, love me, be with me, be with me.
那不再是那种“爱我吧，爱我吧，跟我在一起，跟我在一起”的感觉。
I love you.
我爱你。
Do you love me?
你爱我吗？
Like it was such a different gear, which is like I think you're being unkind yeah, and I don't like it Yeah, you know it there was there was a kind of like Like a propulsive energy to it.
就好像它是完全不同的另一种状态，大概就是我觉得你很不厚道，对，而且我不喜欢这样，对，你知道的，这里面有一种——有一种类似向前的推进力。
Yeah, I just need to yell.
对，我就是需要大吼大叫。
We never yell That was a I think that was a carter line I think Carter was probably channeling a bunch of his like pre pre marriage breakups in this one Yeah, winning the breakup I feel like Carter was definitely bringing some real wounds into this and I remember loving that we never did this We never yelled.
我们从不吼叫。那应该——我觉得那是卡特的台词，我想卡特当时可能是在这一段里融入了他自己的一大堆婚前分手经历。对，在分手这件事上占上风，我觉得卡特绝对是把一些真实的伤痛带到了这场戏里。我记得我很喜欢这一点：我们以前从不这样。我们从不吼叫。所以现在我们不得不吼了，我觉得这是卡特一个非常棒的观察，但它又是那么滑稽——你知道的，它就好像是一个很平庸的——我喜欢罗宾说“我喜欢这个胡子”的那段，我也挺喜欢。虽然他们其实是在往回走，当它开始滑落的时候，但不管怎样，他大喊大叫纯粹是为了喊而喊。这太人性化了。对，他们在建立连接，而且她看着他那副非得大吼大叫的样子，脸上流露出半笑不笑的神情，她由着他。然后她说我也很痛苦。这其实是一场非常可爱的戏。
So now we have to and I feel like I feel like it was a great Carter observation, but it's such a funny You know, it's such a pedestrian like I like where she said I like the beard.
（注：此块对应上一条被长合并的字幕，保持原样空置）
I did too And they're going back once it's falling, but yeah, he's just yelling to yell.
（注：同上）
He just has to yell something It's so human Yeah, and they're connecting and she's kind of half smiling at the fact that he's he just has to yell and she lets him And then she says I'm in pain too.
It's actually a lovely scene.
（注：同上）
Yeah, I that's cool to hear that you like that scene that much You guys played it really beautiful.
对，听到你那么喜欢那场戏，真的挺酷的。你们俩演得太美妙了。我是认真的，而且我还觉得……
I really do and I also think The tat I mean the way that they get out of that scene you're bigger is so Funny and also like he's fine.
泰德——我是说，他们结束那场戏的方式，你那玩意儿更大，实在是太逗了。而且就好像——他没事。
It's a very human.
这非常人性化。太、太人性化了。
It's very very human.
这非常直男。
It's very male Yeah, like and also like a little a little gift I want, does he say I won at the end with the testing?
对，还有点像——一个小小的奖励，我想，他在结尾测试的时候是不是说了句“我赢了”？
Yeah, I won.
对，我赢了。
Which is, we're all humans, man, right?
这不就是我们所有人吗，伙计，对吧？
We all need, he needed to know, the deeper thing he needed to know was that she was actually hurt and she wasn't just blissfully happy and that she was compensating in some way.
我们都需要——他真正需要知道的更深层的事情是，其实她也受伤了，她并不只是盲目地快乐，她其实是在用某种方式进行心理补偿。
And the cherry on top was Ted's got a bigger dick.
而锦上添花的就是泰德的鸡巴更大。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, also real quick though, there's a, the, the, the slap that tag is great.
对，不过说句题外话，还有一个——那个片尾笑点太棒了。
That, that was, I, I really forgot.
那个，我——我真的给忘了。
We did that.
我们居然拍了那个。
I totally forgot about that.
我完全把那事儿给忘光了。
I really forgot we did that at the end of that episode.
我真的忘了我们在那一集的结尾搞了这么一出。
And I was like, the fucking balls on us that there's not one mention of the slap that.
然后我当时就想，我们俩真特么有种，居然对那个巴掌梗只字不提。
No, but that was a reward for people who had been watching.
不，但这对于一直在看的观众来说是个奖励。
That's it.
就是这样。
We're giving, we're really, that is our message and a bottle to the the dedicated viewer were saying, we know you're there.
我们在给，我们真的，那是我们给忠实观众的一封漂流瓶信，我们在说，我们知道你在那儿。
We know you're watching the show with that level of scrutiny.
我们知道你正在以这种程度的细致度观看这部剧。
And we really love you.
我们真的很爱你。
You have a different level of satisfaction with this show that the drop-in viewer doesn't know.
你对这部剧有着一种全新的满足感，这是偶尔点进来的观众所不知道的。
But the drop-in viewer would be like, what in God's name is this?
但偶尔点进来的观众会想：这特么到底是什么鬼？
It's not explained.
没有解释。
It's not enough.
还不够。
Maybe it was mysterious enough that people would be like, that's intriguing and weird.
也许它的神秘感足以让人们觉得，这挺吸引人也挺诡异的。
Yeah.
是的。
This show is maybe weirder than I thought it was.
这部剧可能比我想象的还要诡异。
Well, it was a good one.
好吧，这集很棒。
I really love this episode.
我真的很喜欢这一集。
I really, again, just to bring it, but we will have a deeper talk about our emotional states headed into this episode at some point.
真的，再次重申，我们稍后会更深入地谈谈我们进入这一集时的情绪状态。
But this episode meant a lot, it brought me back to life a little bit after I had had, you know, a near death hiatus, certainly an emotional near death and sort of a literal one.
但这一集意义重大，在我经历了一段可以说是濒死边缘的间歇期——当然是情感上的濒死，某种程度上也是字面意义上的——之后，它让我重新焕发了一点生机。
And coming back and feeling like this show was firing on all its cylinders.
当归来时，感觉这部剧火力全开。
Oh my God, yeah.
天哪，是的。
Really strong season premiere.
非常棒的季首播。
It's hard, season premiere is hard.
很难，季首播很难。
launch a whole new thing, launch a whole new condition, pick up on where you left off, but also spin it into something new, hard stuff to do.
开启全新事物，开启全新状况，从你离开的地方继续，但也要把它变成全新的东西，这很难做到。
I actually was really proud of it, watching it.
看的时候，我其实真的很为它骄傲。
I hadn't watched this one in you.
我很久没看过这一集了。
I felt like every character was saying the thing the character would say, if that makes it.
我觉得每个角色都在说这个角色该说的话，如果这样说得通的话。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Like Robin was so Robin, and Barney was so Barney, and Ted was so Ted.
比如罗宾太像罗宾了，巴尼太像巴尼了，泰德太像泰德了。
Like everyone was really finally etched in a way that you want it to feel that way.
就像每个人终于都被刻画成了你所希望的那种感觉。
We were just starting to feel like maybe the show could be a hit, and you're still trying to just prove yourself and prove who these characters are.
我们当时才刚开始觉得这部剧可能会火，而你还在努力证明自己，证明这些角色是谁。
And if people are dropping viewers, you're trying to say like, I want this to be crystal clear to you, except the tag, which is gonna confuse the shit out of you.
如果有人是偶尔观看的观众，你会想说：我希望这对你来说晶莹剔透、一目了然，除了那个会把你搞得一头雾水的片尾彩蛋。
But that's also some of the joy.
但这也是乐趣的一部分。
Do you know what Jordana said to me the moment the show, this episode ended?
你知道乔达娜在这集结束的那一刻对我说什么吗？
What?
什么？
She turned her back to me and she said, massage me like Gaiel.
她背对着我说：像盖尔一样给我按摩。
We are now at what we like to call an industry speak, our sea block, Alec, what do you have for us?
我们现在来到了行业黑话中所谓的“C板块”，亚历克，你给我们准备了什么？
Well, this season, this season, I think if all goes well, and I'm speaking to you all out there, you can hear me, we're going to hear from a bunch of folks who helped make this show kind of behind the scenes as well as in front of the camera, certainly.
嗯，这一季，这一季，我想如果一切顺利的话——我在对你们所有人说话，你们能听到我——我们会听到很多幕后以及镜头前（当然）为这部剧做出贡献的人的声音。
And I do have our first hello for you guys and I'm going to talk about doing more of this Alec.
我确实为你们准备了第一个问候，而且我要多做一点这种环节，亚历克。
You shouldn't have.
你本不必这样的。
You will.
你会的。
So and so you did it.
所以，你做了。
And this one's going to be from Kelly who started out as a production assistant, but spent most of her time there as the production coordinator.
这一条来自凯莉，她最初是一名制作助理，但大部分时间都在那里担任制作统筹。
Hi guys, it's Kelly.
大家好，我是凯莉。
I love that you're doing season three season three holds a very, very special place in my heart because it's the season that I started and it's the season that I met all of you and I just it's basically when I feel like my career I had done a couple of shows before but I feel like it's kind of when my career kind of got its legs I got to spend seven and a half I think glorious seasons with all of you.
我很高兴你们在做第三季，第三季在我心中占据着非常非常特殊的位置，因为这是我加入的那一季，也是我结识你们所有人的那一季，我只是觉得——基本上就是从那时起，我觉得我的职业生涯……我之前做过几个节目，但我觉得那是我的职业生涯真正开始站稳脚跟的时候。我有幸和你们所有人度过了可以说是辉煌的七个半季节。
I learned so much about production and the business and my job and life, and I met so many amazing people who are still my friends to this day and a lot of the co-workers that I still work with to this day.
我学到了很多关于制作、行业、我的工作以及生活的知识，我遇到了那么多直到今天依然是我的朋友的优秀人士，还有很多直到今天我依然在合作的同事。
And I just got to hang out with magical people and do an experience and see so many amazing things.
我只是去和神奇的人们一起闲逛，经历了一段经历，看到了那么多神奇的事情。
And I just got to start all of it in season three.
而这一切我都是从第三季开始的。
And so really season three changed my life.
所以第三季真的改变了我的生活。
And it's always going to hold a special place in my heart because of that.
正因如此，它永远在我心中占据着特殊的位置。
Love you.
爱你们。
Kelly.
凯莉。
Oh my gosh, that's so nice to hear from Kelly.
噢天哪，听到凯莉的消息太好了。
Kelly was with us from that moment until the end, worked in production, and she was in utter delight and array of sunshine all the time.
凯莉从那个时候一直陪我们到最后，从事制作工作，她一直都是个绝对的开心果和阳光般的存在。
You could not all see ever seeing a scowl on Kelly's face.
你永远不可能看到凯莉的脸上带着怒容。
No, all positivity, smiling and so.
没错，全是积极向上、满脸笑容。
Yes, she was part of the fabric right away, right away became that.
是的，她立刻就成为了这个集体的一部分，立刻就成为了那样的人。
Kelly, you became that right away, and you were you were a heart and soul him.
凯莉，你立刻就成为了那样的人，你是我们的心和灵魂。
You were the moment you started till the moment the show ended.
从你开始的那一刻到节目结束的那一刻，你都是。
So thank you.
所以谢谢你。
That's so nice to hear.
听到这些太美妙了。
All right.
好的。
And now we've also got what we've got.
现在我们还有我们有什么。
We've got letters.
我们有信件。
We've got voice bells coming in.
我们有语音留言。
Josh, you want to tell us all about that for our new listeners.
乔什，你想为我们的新听众介绍一下这部分吗？
And we've got our first letter of the season.
我们还有本季的第一封信。
Sure.
当然。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, one of our favorite things on the show is hearing from you, hearing from fans, hearing from people who, how they discovered how I met your mother, what it has meant to them, how it's impacted their lives.
嗯，我们在节目中最喜欢的事情之一就是听到你们的声音，听到粉丝们的声音，听到人们讲述他们是如何发现《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的，这部剧对他们意味着什么，它如何影响了他们的生活。
You wouldn't believe the beautiful synchronic stories we get to hear at such a treat, it's one of our favorite things about the show.
你不会相信我们能听到那些美妙而巧合的故事，这真是一种享受，这是我们对这个节目最喜爱的地方之一。
If you would like to share your story with us, either as a voice note or in a written letter, please go to how we made your mother.com, h-w-m-y-m.com, go to contact and it should be pretty clear from there how to do that.
如果你想与我们分享你的故事，可以通过语音便签或写信的方式，请访问 how we made your mother.com，即 h-w-m-y-m.com，点击联系页面，从那里应该能很清楚地知道该怎么做。
But please let us know.
但请让我们知道。
We are always delighted to hear from you.
听到你们的消息我们总是很高兴。
And today, we have a letter from Ava.
今天，我们有一封来自艾娃的信。
Hi, Josh Craig and Alec.
嗨，乔什、克雷格和亚历克。
My name is Ava and I live in Northern California.
我叫艾娃，我住在北加州。
I just wanted to let you know how much I'm enjoying the podcast.
我只是想让你们知道我有多么喜欢这个播客。
It truly feels like the gift that keeps on giving.
它真的感觉像是一份源源不断给予的礼物。
I first watched him in college and was immediately hooked after the first few episodes of season one.
我最初是在上大学时看的，在第一季的前几集之后就立刻入坑了。
Old tech alert, I was watching the DVD box set because that's how it was done for you streaming.
老科技警报，我当时在看 DVD 套装，因为在流媒体普及之前就是这么看的。
It has since become my comfort show.
从那以后，它成了我的治愈系剧集。
I've watched it countless times and we even have a pet named Swarley.
我已经看过无数遍了，我们甚至还养了一只叫斯瓦利（Swarley）的宠物。
Amazing.
太棒了。
I'm a public health nurse and I do home visits to support first time moms.
我是一名公共卫生护士，我进行家访来支持新手妈妈。
Many of my clients are navigating financial instability, homelessness, and interpersonal violence, all while adjusting to life with a newborn.
我的许多客户都在应对经济不稳定、无家可归和人际暴力，同时还要适应有新生儿的生活。
As you can imagine, it can feel like the weight of the world is on my shoulders some days.
正如你所想象的那样，有时感觉世界的重担都压在我的肩膀上。
I'm so grateful I can listen to your podcast while driving between visits.
我非常感激在两次访问之间开车时能听你们的播客。
It brings lightness to my day and somehow always leaves me feeling a little more hopeful.
它给我的生活带来了轻松，不知总能让我感到多了一丝希望。
The podcast has also introduced me to so many great things.
这个播客还向我介绍了许多棒极了的事物。
I discovered Craig's debut novel through the show and immediately knew I had to read it.
我通过节目发现了克雷格的处女作小说，并立刻知道我必须读它。
I even made 10 other people read it too as it was my book club pick.
我甚至让其他10个人也读了它，因为它是我的读书俱乐部精选。
You're welcome.
不用谢。
I love, I love Eva, Eva, Eva, whoever it is.
我爱，我爱艾娃、艾娃、艾娃，不管你是谁。
Well, how we pronounce your name, we love you.
好吧，不管我们怎么念你的名字，我们都爱你。
That's not how it happened by Craig.
克雷格的《事情不是这样的》。
Thank you.
谢谢你。
I connected deeply with the characters.
我和这些角色产生了深深的共鸣。
My own daughter has health needs, and I was 12 when my older brother began dealing with serious health issues.
我自己的女儿有健康需求，当我哥哥开始应对严重的健康问题时我才12岁。
He has since had two liver transplants and continues to face everything with more grace, hope, and humor than I could ever imagine.
从那以后他经历过两次肝脏移植，并且继续以超乎我想象的优雅、希望和幽默面对一切。
The podcast also introduced me to some phenomenal music.
这个播客还向我介绍了一些非凡的音乐。
I hadn't heard any of Josh's work before, but now I can't help but sing along to NYC and have been exploring more of his music.
在这之前我没听过乔什的任何作品，但现在我不禁跟着《NYC》一起哼唱，并且一直在探索他更多的音乐。
I always knew him and featured great indie tracks, but I never fully appreciated them until now.
我一直知道它和节目里有很多棒极了的独立音乐，但我直到现在才真正充分地欣赏它们。
I've started to listen to playlists featuring songs from the show, and it makes me picture all the scenes that I'm instantly filled with joy.
我开始听收录了剧中歌曲的播放列表，这让我脑海中浮现出所有的场景，心中瞬间充满了喜悦。
Thank you for creating a show that continues to make me laugh and smile.
谢谢你们创作了一部能让我一直开怀大笑、展颜欢笑的剧集。
And for this podcast that adds so much joy to my daily life, I truly appreciate the company on my commutes and the brightness you bring to my days.
还有这个给我的日常生活增添了这么多快乐的播客，我真的很感激它陪伴我上下班，也感激你们带给我每一天的阳光。
Also, congratulations to Josh and Jordana on your first baby.
另外，恭喜乔什和乔丹娜迎来你们的第一个宝宝。
I'm here for all your first time parent questions.
你们所有关于新手父母的问题我都可以解答。
Lots of love.
爱你们。
Take her up on it.
听她的吧。
She knows.
她懂的。
Oh my God.
天哪。
That was the sweetest letter.
那是写得最贴心的信。
The best.
太棒了。
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
Aren't you honored by like, how articulate, empathetic, kind, and intelligent, how much mother fans are.
难道你们不为《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝们的表达能力、同理心、善良、智慧以及他们的优秀程度感到荣幸吗？
We get these messages that are just unbelievable.
我们收到这些留言简直令人难以置信。
Yeah.
是的。
They're just one person honor, really.
这真是个人的荣誉，真的。
Very human.
非常有人情味。
Human, very human, human, caring.
有人情味，非常有人情味，充满关爱。
You know, did you, have you seen that little like AI kind of meme that's going around of just all the himeum characters on their phones?
你知道，你见过那个在网上流传的关于所有《老爸老妈浪漫史》角色拿着手机的AI恶搞梗图吗？
Yeah.
见过。
Right?
对吧？
I'm saying it.
我正想说这个。
Yeah.
对。
And it's, it's sad.
而且它，它很悲伤。
Like it is sad.
真的挺悲伤的。
It's very sad.
非常悲伤。
It makes me sad.
这让我很难过。
Yes, it does.
是的，确实如此。
Which I guess is the point.
我想这正是它的意义所在。
But I think, you know, Wendell Berry, this great philosopher, farmer poet, he said, there's going to come a time in the future when people are gonna have to choose if they wanna be humans or machines.
但我觉得，你知道的，温德尔·贝里，这位伟大的哲学家、农夫诗人，他说过，未来总有一天，人们将不得不选择是成为人类还是机器。
Yeah.
对。
And I feel like how I met your mother is like pretty team human.
我觉得《老爸老妈浪漫史》非常坚定地站在人类这边。
It is team human.
它属于人类战队。
It's a team human show.
这是一部属于人类的剧集。
There's not a lot of tech.
这里没有太多的科技。
there's just beer and laughter and relationships and quirky, interesting, fun characters.
只有啤酒、欢笑、人际关系，以及古怪、有趣、快乐的角色。
And you can hear it back in these letters that these are human beings that felt like they were watching a very human show and it helped them reflect more deeply on their own human experience.
你可以从这些信件中听出，写信的都是活生生的人，他们觉得自己看了一部极具人情味的剧集，这帮助他们更深刻地反思了自身的人类体验。
Yeah, yeah, it's exactly who you want to believe was watching and is watching our TV show.
对，对，这正是你希望、也是正在收看我们电视剧的人。
Yeah, and who we were making it for.
是的，这也是我们为之创作的人。
You were making it for it.
你们就是为他们创作的。
Like who's on the other end of the line.
就像电话那头的人是谁一样。
We hope it's Ava's.
我们希望那是艾娃。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think with all this time that has passed and all the ways we now can connect with fans, and some of it ironically is through technology, it's a complicated thing, right?
我想随着时间的流逝，以及我们现在与粉丝联系的各种方式，其中有些讽刺的是通过科技实现的，这是一件复杂的事情，对吧？
We're getting social media technology, we are getting some good things too, we're like, we're getting that message and it's just proof positive that the people we're putting our little messages in a bottle to, we're finding them.
我们获得了社交媒体技术，我们也得到了好的方面，比如，我们收到了那条信息，这绝对是铁证，证明我们把装在漂流瓶里的小纸条发送到了正确的地方，我们找到了他们。
It was washing up on the right shores, our little messages and we're so grateful for that.
我们的小纸条冲上了正确的海岸，我们对此感激不尽。
That's the best part to do when this is hearing from you guys, so keep them coming.
制作这个播客最棒的部分就是听到你们的声音，所以请继续发来吧。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《How We Made Your Mother》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Audacy 联合呈献和发行。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
本节目还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利担任执行制片人，由我，亚历克·莱夫担任制作人和剪辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制作人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer, Emily Blumberg, an associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是来自 Point of Blue 蓝点工作室的亚历克斯·里夫斯，我们的Z世代大师、数字内容制作人是艾米莉·布伦贝格，助理制作人是凯瑟琳·格罗夫。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面插图由约翰·莫罗创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
这确实有助于帮我们进行宣传。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是《纽约市》，由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基提供伴奏音乐。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萨姆·西博尔德和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, and check out his music and everything else at joshradner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的 Muse Letters，并在 joshradner.com 上查看他的音乐及其他作品。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and read his other published writing at CraigThomasWriter.com.
在各大书店购买克雷格·托马斯的长篇小说处女作《那不是事情原本的样子》，并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上阅读他的其他出版作品。
And you could subscribe to my own Dead Father Society on Substack.
您还可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的“已故父亲协会”。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research.
要了解本节目为先天性心脏病研究筹款的长期持续活动如何发挥作用，请访问我们网站顶部的“产生影响”标签页。
out the make a difference tab at the top of our website.
了解我们网站顶部的“make a difference”标签。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞的。